sie ist die erste Autorin die
Milliardären geworden ist
es gibt nicht viele Autoren die immer
Bücher in Serie herausbringt die sich
alle am ersten Tag zwölf 15 Millionen
Mal verkaufen
ihre Vorstellungskraft hat Kinder und
Erwachsene begeistert und jede Branche
verändert die sie berührte Harry Potter
selbst war so groß wie ein kleiner
Verlag
Harry Potter ist das Maß aller Dinge es
ist das größte Film Franchise aller
Zeiten aber j.k Rowlings märchenhafte
Erfolg wurde aus Überlebenskampf und
Herzschmerz geboren
ich war arbeitslos und alleinerziehend
ich war die größte Versagerin die ich
kannte mit einem Ende wie aus dem
Bilderbuch Kapitel 1
Mittelpunkt der finanziell
erfolgreichsten Erzählungen der
Geschichte der Belletristik Harry Potter
steht die einzigartige und entschlossene
Joanne rowling
400 Millionen Exemplare den Vereinigten
Staaten und brachte eine Milliarde
Kinder dazu 4 5 600 seitige Wälzer zu
lesen und das in einer Zeit in der
Kinder überhaupt keine Bücher mehr
Blasen
mit wohl über 10 Milliarden Dollar an
Gesamteinnahmen ist das ein absolut
erstaunliches Franchise dass wir meiner
Meinung nach nie wieder sehen werden
die Popularität von Harry Potter hat
rowling in die ungewohnte Welt der
Berühmtheit katapultiert nachdem sie
einst vom Paparazzi gejagt wurde
schränkt sie heute den Zugang zu ihrem
Privatleben ein und lehnte es ab an
dieser Dokumentation mitzuwirken
Joanne rolling wurde 1965 entlastershair
England geboren Schauspieler jimdail der
von rolling als Sprecher für die Harry
Potter Hörbücher in den Vereinigten
Staaten ausgewählt wurde kannte diese
ländlichen Dörfer gut
in diesen kleinen Städten lebten keine
reichen Menschen alle gehörten zur
Arbeiterklasse man gingen die Häuser und
sah dieselbe Tapete die man selbst hatte
denn es gab nur ein einziges
tapetengeschäft in der Stadt es gab nur
einen Genossenschaftsladen und so sah
man dass das gleiche Kleid dass die
eigene Mutter trug auch von zwei oder
drei anderen Frauen getragen wurde das
ist also die Art von Umgebung rollings
literarische Ambitionen wurden schon
früh erkannt
ihr erstes Buch mit dem Titel Hase
stellte sie mit sechs Jahren fertig
Melissa Nelly interviewte rolling für
ihr Buch Harry eine Geschichte voller
Magie
es ging um einen Kaninchen das krank
wird und bei all seinen anderen Hasen
ist und als er es fertig hatte brachte
sie es anscheinend ihrer Mutter und
sagte nun veröffentliche es wird daraus
jetzt etwa kein Buch gemacht
doch hinter dem Selbstvertrauen verbag
sich Unsicherheit wie rolling bei Oprah
gestammt ich bin kein Mensch mit viel
Selbstbewusstsein ich war niemand mit
besonders viel von irgendwas ich würde
sogar sagen ich war jemand mit wenig
Selbstvertrauen und doch glaubte ich an
diese eine Sache in meinem Leben das war
die eine Sache in meinem Leben ich
fühlte dass ich eine Geschichte erzählen
kann ihre Geschichte wurde in taskel
einem kleinen Dorf in der Grafschaft
clusterscher geschrieben Tanja arbeitete
als Produzentin bei den ersten vier
Harry Potter Filmen eng mit rolling
zusammen sie hatte sowohl einen
mikroskopischen als auch einen
mikrokosmischen Blick auf Hogwarts im
Harry Potter Universum sie war im Westen
des Landes aufgewachsen in der Nähe des
Waldes von Wien wo auch ich einen
Großteil meiner Kindheit verbracht hatte
wir hatten also eine Menge gemeinsamer
Bezugspunkte
alles worüber JK in ihren Büchern
schreibt findet sich irgendwo in England
wieder das muss so sein wir haben die
fantastischen alten Schlösser wir haben
diese wunderbaren alten Gebäude
wir haben diese Wälder die man anhand
ihrer Beschreibung selbst kennt oder
dort in der Nähe finden kann wo sie eins
gelebt hat around
1980 wurde bei ihrer Mutter Multiple
Sklerose diagnostiziert ein tragisches
Ereignis für die Familie doch das hielt
rolling nicht davon ab an ihrer
Leidenschaft für die Belletristik weiter
festzuhalten weder in der Schule noch
später am College joe hat in Exeter
classic studiert da kommt alles her ihre
klassische Bildung findet sich in den
Harry Potter Büchern wieder die
griechischen Mythen die christlichen
Allegorien
nach dem College bezahlte rolling ihre
Miete indem sie bei Amnesty
International in London arbeitete wo sie
in ihrer Mittagspause Geschichten
schrieb
1990 hat sie dann in einem Zug nach
London eine Idee die ihr Leben verändern
sollte
dazu blieb stehen und ihr kam
buchstäblich in den Kopf Zauberer Junge
der nicht weiß dass er ein Zauberer ist
geht auf eine Zauberer Schule und weil
sie keinen Stift hatte saß sie
stundenlang da und dachte nach während
der Zug weiter da stand sie fing damit
an der Schule einen Namen zu geben sich
Gedanken über die Lehrer zu machen in
Harry Potter und ich erklärt sie was das
für ein lebensverändernder Moment
gewesen ist
dieses unglaubliche Kribbeln dass man
bekommt wenn man gerade jemanden
kennengelernt hat in dem man sich
vielleicht verlieben wird
die ganze Harry Welt war ihre
Leidenschaft das Ausmaß in dem dieser
enzyklopädische lebendige Verstand
wusste was hinter einer Tür sein würde
von der man noch nicht einmal wusste
dass es überhaupt gab war wirklich
erstaunlich nur sechs Monate später
erhielt sie eine herzzerreißende
Nachricht
ihre Mutter war an Multiple Sklerose
verstorben
rolling sprach mit der BBC über ihren
Verlust
ich habe sechs Monate vor ihrem Tod mit
dem Schreiben von Harry begonnen das ist
das ist natürlich sehr bedauerlich weil
ich ihr nie gesagt habe dass ich
überhaupt schreibe sie hat also nie
etwas von Harry Potter erfahren
der Tod von Joes Mutter hat sich auf ihr
gesamtes schreiben ausgewirkt auf jede
einzelne Seite von Harry Potter er hat
ihre Ansichten von Liebe und Tod
verändert und davon was es bedeutet wenn
uns jemand verlässt und welche
Auswirkungen das auf unser Leben hat sie
konzentrierte sich zunehmend auf den
zauberjungen und wurde schließlich von
mehreren Jobs gefeuert weil sie schrieb
anstatt zu arbeiten das war eine dunkle
Zeit für die arbeitslose Autoren rolling
beschloss England ganz zu verlassen
Joanne rolling verließ England um in
Porto Portugal einen Neuanfang zu machen
sie bekam einen Job als Lehrerin und
schrieb nebenher weiter
rolling heiratete eine lokalen
Fernsehjournalisten und bekam innerhalb
eines Jahres eine Tochter aber nach
einer wie sie es nannte kurzen und
katastrophalen Ehe zog sie nach
Edinburgh Schottland um in der Nähe
ihrer Schwester zu sein
als ich glaube sie fühlte sich ein
bisschen als Versagerin weil sie arm war
weil sie sehr gut ausgebildet war aber
bisher einfach keine Karriere gemacht
hatte sie versuchte einen Job als
Lehrerin zu bekommen aber die Arbeit war
nicht beständig und so musste sie
öffentliche Hilfe in Anspruch nehmen sie
lebte von der Hand in den Mund von Tag
zu Tag in absolute Armut am
Existenzminimum es ist nicht glamourös
und nicht romantisch aber es hat dazu
beigetragen dass dieses Buch
letztendlich in Produktion ging
rolling sagte dass der Tiefpunkt die
Grundlage für den Wiederaufbau ihres
Lebens war
ich schrieb in der Wärme eines Kaffees
weiter während ihre Tochter neben ihr
schlief
[Musik]
und als sie die ersten drei Kapitel
hatte mit denen sie zufrieden war
schickte sie sie an einen Agenten
es wurde abgelehnt in 1995 schickte sie
drei Kapitel an die Agentur von Chris
little dort wurde es genauso behandelt
wie es für Werke unbekannte Autoren
üblich war wie little in Sixty minutes
erzählte
diese Dinge können ewig auf einem Stapel
liegen man nennt ihn auch den
matschhaufen aber wie ist der Zufall
wollte nahm ich zwei Tage später diesen
Stapel in die Hand und nahm ihn mit zum
Mittagessen weil meine Begleitung spät
dran war und drinnen begann ich von
Harry Potter zu lesen und wir stellten
sich die Nackenhaare auf aber
zollverleger lehnten das Buch ab
niemand wollte weil es damals politisch
unkorrekt war Internate zu bewerben es
war zweimal so lang wie ein Kinderbuch
sein durfte er hat es hatte diesen
ellenlangen Titel Harry Potter und der
Stein der Weisen es war genau das was
Verleger damals nicht an Büchern haben
wollten und so brachte er es nicht an
den Mann
das Buch fand schließlich seinen Weg zu
einem neuen Kinderbuchverlag namens
Bloomsbury
Potter Bib ist medienanalyst und
ehemaliger Verleger
die Tochter des Geschäftsführers hat die
ersten beiden Kapitel gelesen ging zu
ihrem Vater und sagte sie wolle mehr
davon lesen das ist eben auch das schöne
am Verlagswesen go es geht zu einem
großen Teil ums Bauchgefühl
[Musik]
1996 sechs Jahre nach dem rolling mit
dem Schreiben von Harry Potter begonnen
hatte bot Bloomsbury ihr 4000 Dollar für
das Buch an das war nicht viel aber für
rolling war es magisch Magic der Moment
in dem man mir sagte dass Bloomsbury das
Buch übernehmen wollte war nach der
Geburt meiner Tochter der glücklichste
Moment meines Lebens
aber es gab einen Haken um die
Marktfähigkeit zu verbessern wollte
Bloomsbury dass sie ihren Namen in etwas
geschlechtsneutrales ändert wie little
in Sixty minutes erklärte
traditionell lesen Jungs nicht gerne
Bücher die von Mädchen geschrieben
wurden Mädchen ist es egal wer die
Bücher geschrieben hat aber Jungs haben
diese seltsame sexistische Einstellung
Joanne Liese ich von ihrer Großmutter
Kathleen eine mittlere initiale und
wurde JK Rowling
auf der Buchmesse in Bologna 1997 sprach
sich das Buch schnell herum AfA eleven
Vizepräsident von skolastik war dorthin
geflogen um nach etwas Besonderem zu
suchen
ich wollte Bücher finden die nicht nur
im Trend liegen oder gerade populär sind
sondern die von den Kindern wirklich
geliebt und ihre Lieblingsbücher werden
Michael Jacobs war zu diesem Zeitpunkt
10 Jahre vice president der
Handelsabteilung von skolastic
es war sicherlich ein Buch das in
Bologna viel Aufsehen erregt hat und ich
glaube für AfA war es ziemlich
offensichtlich dass das Buch das
Potenzial für eine Serie hatte aber das
erste Buch war schon an und für sich
außergewöhnlich Stan alone
Levin bot eine beispiellose Summe von
105.000 Dollar für die amerikanischen
rechte Hand im ersten Harry Potter Buch
als Joe den Anruf von Christopher little
erhielt der ihr sagte dass ihr Buch für
105.000 Dollar nach Amerika verkauft
wurde sagte sie dass sie zum ersten Mal
sehr erschrocken war es war einfach
überwältigend um ehrlich zu sein hatte
mich das Leben in den letzten Jahren so
sehr gebeutelt dass ich ziemlich
misstrauisch war wenn ich gute
Nachrichten erhielt die guten
Nachrichten wurden mehr 1997 wurde das
Buch in Großbritannien veröffentlicht
und wurde zum Erfolg
die erste Generation der Schulhof Potter
Fans war geboren
Joanne Rowlings zweites Buch war bereits
in Arbeit nachdem der erste Harry Potter
zu einem Spitzenpreis ans golestic
verkauft worden war sie spürte einen
enormen Druck den Schwung beizubehalten
der Verkauf nach Amerika war in England
eine große Sache eine unbekannte
britische Autorin verkauft ihr erstes
Buch auf dem amerikanischen Markt der im
Gegensatz zum englischen Markt 5 oder 6
mal so groß ist es war wie die
Geschichte vom Tellerwäscher eine arme
Autorin wurde zum Millionärin die
amerikanischen Verleger hofften dass
Harry Potter abliefern würde
special Hand die neue wir wussten dass
wir etwas Besonderes in den Händen
hielten und das wussten wir schon
ziemlich früh unser Ansatz war also
wirklich ist wie einen Blockbuster zu
veröffentlichen
[Applaus]
Woche wegen Harry Potter traf skolastik
entschied sich für einen interaktiven
Ansatz zur Vermarktung des
wir haben das Buch einigen auserwählten
vor Veröffentlichung zum Lesen gegeben
ich glaube einige von ihnen haben
rolling sogar treffen dürfen bevor das
Buch überhaupt veröffentlicht wurde auf
diese Weise haben wir also einen riesen
Wirbel ausgelöst und als das Buch dann
in den Verkauf ging verbreitete es sich
wie ein Lauffeuer Harry Potter und der
Stein der Weisen verkaufte sich in zehn
Monaten über 800.000 Mal und stand über
ein Jahr lang auf der Bestsellerliste
der New York Times
als der zweite Teil 1999 in den USA die
Läden kam wurde die Veröffentlichung der
potterbücher zu einem großen Ereignis
scolastic zog die Öffentlichkeit in
seinen Bann
[Applaus]
veranstalteten zu jedem neuen Titel der
herauskam ein Spektakel seit dem
buchstäblich Tausende von Kindern vor
den Buchläden standen meistens Kostüm
mitten in der Nacht um ein Exemplar
abzubekommen
Logistik an einem Tag 10 oder 11
Millionen Exemplare eines Buches auf den
Markt zu bringen war schwierig wie sie
sich sicher vorstellen können die Bücher
zu transportieren dafür zu sorgen dass
sie sicher und verschlossen waren
sicherzustellen dass die Bücher
niemandem in die Hände fielen bevor sie
in jedermanns Hände gelangten die
Verkaufszahlen jedes einzelnen Buches
stiegen exponentiell an die erste
Auflagen wurden viel viel größer die
einzige dunkle Wolke die einen Schatten
auf das wachsende Phänomen warf waren
Proteste konservative religiöser Gruppen
die in den mystischen Geschichten das
Böse sahen sie beschuldigten rolling
Hexerei und Okkultismus zu fördern und
verbrannten ihre Bücher
[Musik]
auch wenn Harry Potter gerade die Welt
im Sturm erobert hat ist Hexerei keine
Produktion und keine Fantasie Hexerei
ist real der Teufel ist real
wenn die Leute der Meinung sind das
Hexerei in Kinderbüchern per se nichts
zu suchen hat dann ist die Debatte
wirklich sinnlos denn viele klassische
Kinderbücher würden aus den
bibliotheksregalen verschwinden wie der
Zauberer von Oz
selbst Kardinal Josef Ratzinger jetzt
Papst Benedikt x hatte seine eigenen
Vorbehalte und die amerikanische
bibliotheksvereinigung führte rollings
Buch als den am meisten angefochtenen
Text in den Vereinigten Staaten an
dieser Gegenwind hatte allerdings keinen
Einfluss auf die Verkaufszahlen die
anhaltende Vorherrschaft von Harry
Potter auf der Bestsellerliste der New
York Times zwang die Zeitung schließlich
dazu eine eigene Kategorie für
Kinderbücher einzuführen ich bin mir
sicher dass unsere Konkurrenten
glücklich darüber waren dass sie wieder
mehr Plätze auf der Bestsellerliste für
sich beanspruchen können denn wir hätten
wahrscheinlich mit den ersten fünf
Büchern die Top 5 dominiert
sogar die hörbuchverkäufe brachen
Rekorde und verzauberten die Fans wie
Erzähler jimdale nach einer Live Lesung
in New York feststellte
400 Kinder und Mütter waren da und ein
Kind schrieb plötzlich auf du hast einen
Satz ausgelassen als ob es der größte
Fehler wäre und die Mutter sagte bitte
entschuldigen Sie ihn aber er hat das
ganze Buch auswendig gelernt und aus dem
Publikum hörte ich andere kleine Stimmen
sagen ich auch ich auch
frei
internationale Vertriebe schnappten sich
die Rechte zu Übersetzung der Bücher und
Harry Potter wurde zu einer weltweiten
Sensation
[Musik]
die Nachfrage wurde so groß dass für die
Marke Harry Potter die Gefahr bestand
außer Kontrolle zu geraten
[Musik]
Supermärkte Lebensmittelläden
Tankstellen und andere Einzelhändler die
plötzlich Harry Potter Bücher haben
wollten um den Umsatz anzukurbeln als
Lockvogelangebot für Ihr Geschäft
rowling lehnte hunderte von
lizenzangeboten von Sony Microsoft und
Boeing ab blieb aber ihrer Vision treu
wie sie hier in Sixty minutes erzählte
hier und Sixty Minute wenn die Leute
sehen könnten was für Angebote ich
bekommen habe um Harry in Werbung und
jeder Menge lächerlicher Dinge nutzen zu
dürfen ich habe ausnahmslos alle
abgelehnt
aber es gab ein Angebot aus Hollywood
dass sie nicht ablehnen konnte und ein
Filmstudio war dabei herauszufinden dass
Harry Potter wahre Wunder bewirken
könnte ich arbeitete für eine neue
Produktionsfirma von David Hayman der zu
mir sagte nun ich las einen
Zeitungsartikel in dem stand dass jemand
das erste Buch einer siebenteiligen
Serie über einen kleinen Jungen
geschrieben hatte der auf ein Internat
geht und entdeckt dass er ein Zauberer
ist ich mich also mit ihrem Agenten traf
und versuchte ihn davon zu überzeugen
uns das Buch zu verkaufen traten wir als
Warner Brothers auf all the garderidian
ist Präsident des china-resorts von
Hollywood.com
[Musik]
ich glaube für Warner Brothers war es
eine Mission dass Harry Potter Franchise
zu bekommen ich meine Warner Brothers
hatte großen Erfolg mit dem Batman
Franchise mit dem Matrix Franchise und
ich glaube sie waren fest entschlossen
ist zu schaffen und ich glaube deshalb
haben sie j.k rowling so viel Spielraum
gegeben was ihre Kontrolle über diesen
Prozess und über die Filmreihe angeht
unser erstes Treffen mit j.k rowling
fand beim Mittagessen statt David Hayman
und ich hatten ihr ein wenig darüber
erzählt was wir mit dem Film machen
wollten und sie setzte sich mit uns
zusammen wir versuchten verzweifelt sie
zu beeindrucken sie brauchte uns
natürlich nicht zu beeindrucken denn das
hatte sie bereits getan JK Rowling hat
angeblich 2 Millionen Dollar von Warner
Brothers für die Rechte an den ersten
vier Filmen erhalten
es gibt nicht viele Autorinnen und
Autoren die immer der Bücher einer Serie
herausbringen die sich alle am ersten
Tag ziehen 12 15 Millionen Mal verkaufen
das gab ja eine Menge Einfluss so konnte
sie verlangen dass der Film in
Großbritannien mit einer rein britischen
Besetzung gedreht wird und dass sie
sowohl bei der Auswahl der Schauspieler
als auch der Regisseure ein Wort
mitzureden hatte
top-regisseure bulten um Zutritt zu
rollings imaginärer Welt nun ich weiß
dass man an Steven Spielberg herantragt
um beim ersten Harry Potter Film Regie
zu führen er wollte ihn eigentlich als
Animationsfilm machen aber das kam nicht
zustande und so sprang Chris Columbus
ein Produzent David haimen stellte die
handverlesene Besetzung in einem Warner
Brothers Video vor
Chris Wahl von drei wunderbaren
britischen Schauspielern für die
Hauptrollen zeigt wie gut er den Geist
dieser Bücher versteht ich glaube ihr
wichtigstes Anliegen bei der Verfilmung
ihrer Vision war dass wir den Büchern
treu bleiben ich glaube sie hatte
wirklich unglaublich hart daran
gearbeitet Charaktere in einer
Geschichte zu erschaffen an die sie
glaubte und sie wollte nicht dass das
zerhackt und falsch interpretiert wird
die größte Herausforderung dabei j.k
Rowlings Vision auf die Leinwand zu
kriegen bestand darin dass zu dem
Zeitpunkt als wir filmten bereits jeder
das Buch gelesen hatte
hätten sie sich das jemals erträumen
können nicht in einer Millionen Jahren
das war das letzte was ich erwartet
hatte der erste Harry Potter Film kam im
November 2001 in die Kinos wieder einmal
bewirkte der zauberjunge wunder
wunderschön
mit 90,3 Millionen eingespielten Dollar
war es das erfolgreichste
Eröffnungswochenende des Jahres der Film
spielte anschließend 317 Millionen
Dollar ein und war damit der größte
einspielerfolg an den heimischen
Kinokassen im Jahr 2001 rolling behielt
nicht nur die kreative Kontrolle sondern
handelte auch einen unbekannten
Prozentsatz der Film und lizenzgewinne
aus
viel wichtiger ist aber dass sie mit dem
Endprodukt zufrieden war
gestern ich glaube als ich ihre Reaktion
auf die fertigen Filme sah habe ich
gedacht wir haben es geschafft es ist
alles in Ordnung wir haben Sie nicht im
Stich gelassen
2001 war auch das Jahr in dem Joanne
rowling ihren zweiten Mann Doktor Neil
Michael Mary heiratete
und die Harry Potter Filme sind
weiterhin ein Kassenschlager
jeder Harry Potter Film stieg zum Start
auf Platz 1 der Kinocharts die Filmreihe
hat einen perfekten
eröffnungswochenendrekord aufgestellt
wir reden hier über ein Jahrzehnt wir
reden über sieben Filme
[Musik]
das Einspielergebnis der sieben Harry
Potter Filme ohne den zweiten Teil von
die Heiligtümer des Todes liegt bei 6,4
Milliarden Dollar da sind Heimvideos
Fanartikel jegliche Art von Soundtracks
und alles andere noch nicht einmal mit
eingerechnet es ist das größte Film
Franchise aller Zeiten
[Musik]
rolling erhält auch einen Anteil an den
Verkäufen der Harry Potter Spielzeuge
von Mattel und ihr Fanartikel Imperium
expandiert weiter
one etwas zu finden das nicht irgendwann
einmal mit einem Harry Potter Bild
versehen war sei es in der Gaming
Spielzeug oder sogar Bekleidungsbranche
das ist eine Norma Erfolg
2010 bekam Harry Potter seinen eigenen
Themenpark in den Universal Studios in
Orlando der den Namen The Wizarding
World of Harry Potter trägt Harry und
wieder einmal drückte rolling allem
ihren persönlichen Stempel auf vom
Schnee auf dem Dach bis zum Geschmack
des butterbiers sie haben wirklich alle
Zutaten eingetütet sind nach Edinburgh
gefahren haben es hergestellt und dass
ihr präsentiert das da das ist
Butterbier
sie hat zwei weitere Kinder bekommen und
lebt jetzt auf einem pastoralen Landgut
den Nordschottland
und fünf Jahre nach dem letzten Potter
Buch veröffentlichte rowling einen neuen
Roman für Erwachsene
ich bin von Drachen und Einhörnern und
all dem Spaß der mit dem Schreiben
dieser Dinge verbunden ist zu einem Buch
übergegangen das sehr persönlich ist und
viel von meiner Realität ausdrückt
das Buch mit dem Titel ein plötzlicher
Todesfall wirkte nicht den gleichen
Zauber auf Kritiker wurde aber trotzdem
zur Nummer eins auf den Bestsellerlisten
rolling hat Erfolg in der literarischen
Welt neu definiert
hier Nettovermögen wird auf fast eine
Milliarde Dollar geschätzt womit sie zu
den reichsten Frauen der Welt gehört
[Musik]
sie hat sich zu einer wunderbaren Marke
entwickelt was ihre Statur ihre Ethik
und ihr Verhalten angeht
ihre Großzügigkeit erstreckt sich auf
Wohltätigkeitsorganisationen zur
Unterstützung von Kindern
alleinerziehende Eltern armen Menschen
und die multiple skleroseforschung
17 Jahre lang hat rowling Harry Potter
gelebt und geatmet ihre Geschichte war
ähnlich wie seine von der Überwindung
schreckliche Herausforderungen auf dem
Weg zur außergewöhnlichen Erfolg geprägt
wie sie 2008 der harvard-abschlussklasse
erzählte zu wissen dass man aus
Rückschlägen weiser und stärker
hervorgegangen ist bedeutet dass man
sich seiner Fähigkeit zu überleben immer
sicher sein kann man wird sich selbst
oder die Stärke seiner Beziehung erst
dann wirklich kennen wenn beides durch
Widrigkeiten auf die Probe gestellt
wurde ein solches Wissen ist ein wahres
Geschenk denn es war schmerzhaft
errungen und es war mehr wert als jede
qu Kommunikation die ich jemals erworben
habe
[Applaus]
[Musik]
er war nur eins dieser Straßenkinder
jetzt ist er ein Geschäftsführer mit
einem globalen 450 Millionen Dollar
Imperium ich glaube nicht dass JC jemals
nur ein Musiker war er dachte er ich
werde das jayzee Unternehmen aufbauen
niemand hätte gedacht dass er so weit
kommen würde dass er Clubs und
Modelinien besitzen würde und alles
andere was er tut
er hat damit geprahlt über die Grenzen
der Musik hinauszugehen und das ist ihm
gelungen
ist nicht zum Mainstream übergegangen er
nahm den ganzen Mainstream und kaufte
Ihnen eine Eintrittskarte in seine Welt
er entkam dem dunklen Weg den so viele
andere genommen hatten es passiert die
ganze Zeit in diesem Wohnprojekt du hast
ein bestimmtes Leben und es wird
nirgendwohin es führt entweder ins
Gefängnis oder es führt zum Tod seine
Überlebensfähigkeit und
Selbstdarstellung führten ihn auf die
Reise seines Lebens
von der Straßenecke zum Eckbüro als Chef
das war bahnbrechend Jazz Jay Z ist ein
brillanter Text da er ist ein
skrupelloser Geschäftsmann und jemand
den jedes große Unternehmen gerne an der
Spitze haben würde
sie hatte diese schrittweise aber sehr
tiefgreifende Entwicklung vom Stricher
zum Chef und zu dieser phänomenalen
hip-hop-größe
anstatt nur irgendeiner zu sein hat er
sich zum Ziel gesetzt der eine zu sein
und das ist einfach eine unglaubliche
Leistung zu sagen ich bin nicht einer
sondern der eine
und das ist er der unbeholfene Junge auf
dem klassenportrait Sean Corey Carter
der zum Mega-Star Jason
Jason nicht teilnehmen
John Carter wurde am 4 Dezember 69 in
Brooklyn New York geboren und war das
jüngste von vier Kindern
Autor Jack Brown
aus der Hölle aus einem Kriegsgebiet das
war dieser Wohnkomplex morsey projects
in den 80ern die Tatsache dass er das
überlebt hat so glaubwürdig im Spiel zu
bleiben ist einzigartig
Rapper Kollege und früher Mentor Jazz o
lebte im selben Wohnprojekt
wir haben mit viel Gewalt zu tun gehabt
wissen sie viel mords Drogenhandel
Drogenmissbrauch Armut
das war ein Glück für einige von uns
daraus zu kommen aber viele die
bekannten haben es nie geschafft
seine Musik handelte von seiner bewegten
Vergangenheit aber er sprach selten
darüber sein offenes einstündiges
Interview mit Charlie Rose im Jahr 2007
war eine Ausnahme die Dinge die in
diesen Vierteln an einem Tag passiert
sind erleben andere in ihrem ganzen
Leben nicht ich habe einen Blick auf
dieses Leben geworfen was mir hätte
passieren können wenn ich auf der Straße
geblieben wäre
sie spielen russisches Roulette mit
ihrem Leben jeden Tag 365 Tage im Jahr
irgendwann knallst du so ist das
gab immer eine Beerdigung
in der sechsten Klasse
diese Kinder sind mit Schusswunden ins
Bett gegangen wenn sie in meinen
Klassenzimmer kamen dösten viele von
ihnen und ich ließ sie weil ich wusste
dass sie die halbe Nacht wach waren
sie hat den jungen Sean curricata nie
vergessen er war schüchtern und extrem
aufgeweckt er war überdurchschnittlich
gut im Lesen er hatte diese angeborene
Fähigkeit
später rebte er darüber gute Noten zu
bekommen aber dass er tief in seinem
Inneren Dämonen hatte die aufgeweckt
wurden er lächelte selten und ich weiß
nicht ob es Traurigkeit war oder einfach
nur seine Persönlichkeit aber er war
immer irgendwie gelassen und lächelte
nicht
als Jaycee 11 Jahre alt war verließ sein
Vater die Familie in seinem Song
December Force sein Geburtsdatum
schreibt er er sei ein zerrissenes Kind
Musikjournalist sect omelly Greenberg
gemacht und isoliert er war sehr
verletzt und ich glaube das hat ihn zu
dem berechnenden Geschäftsmann gemacht
der erot ist unsettimental
seine Texte spiegeln Distanz wieder und
manchmal Wut
in seinen eigenen Songs er habe seinen
Bruder in die Schulter geschossen weil
er ein Schmuckstück gestohlen hat
das Geld war knapp für seine
alleinerziehende berufstätige Mutter und
es gab nur wenige Jobs für einen
Teenager
aber der Drogenhandel brachte das
schnelle Geld
die JAM ist dass sie ein führender new
yorker-dj
es ging darum schnell große Summen
Bargeld zu haben und niemandem
Rechenschaft ablegen zu müssen
im Grunde ging es darum Geld zu
verdienen so gut wir konnten und als er
jung war war das halt Crack verkaufen
auf der Straße
Barry Michael Cooper Journalist und
Filmemacher
es ist eigentlich seltsam der
crackverkauf hat im beigebracht
Unternehmer zu sein die Bedürfnisse und
Wünsche der Leute zu verstehen und eine
Nische in dieser trümmerwelt zu finden
seine Liebe zur Welt der Platten begann
zu Hause
seine Mutter hatte diese Plattensammlung
die in der Gegend legendär war und jeder
kam immer um Musik zu hören
er hat ein enzyklopädisches Wissen über
alle möglichen Musikstile
es ist nicht nur Hip-Hop Marvin Gaye
Curtis Mayfield Barry White James Brown
natürlich
[Musik]
Jay Z bekam keine musikalische
Ausbildung hatte aber instinktiv das
Gefühl das rept seinen Weg aus diesem
Leben sein könnte er schrieb Texte auf
Servietten auf Papiertüten es strömte
aus ihm heraus
er hat gesagt dass er sieben oder acht
neue Songs gleichzeitig im Kopf
speichern kann das sagt wirklich etwas
über die Datenmenge aus die er
verarbeiten kann
Jay Z war eher ein sehr schneller Rapper
aber seine Rap-Songs hatten auch
Melodien das war einzigartig zu der Zeit
das Album hatte keinen Erfolg und Jaycee
kehrte nach Hause zurück
seit kurzer Ausflug in die
Plattenindustrie war eine Enttäuschung
hatte ihm aber die Augen für eine viel
größere Welt geöffnet
er war fokussiert genug um zu sagen
weißt du was ich kann das nicht ewig
machen mit drogendealen denn das kann
nur auf zwei Arten Enden entweder du
stirbst oder du gehst ins Gefängnis
ich hatte tolle Leute um mich herum als
ich an dieser Weggabelung stand soll ich
Entertainer werden oder auf der Straße
bleiben ich habe mich entschieden
Entertainer zu werden und es hat
geklappt ich habe den richtigen Weg
eingeschlagen und habe es nie bereut
er machte sich in einer anderen Art von
Straßenschlacht einen Namen
es gab webcamer auf der Straße wie
Nahkämpfe Acapella einfach aufeinander
losgehen und so hat sich Jay durch die
Straßenschlachten einen Namen gemacht
und alle dachten wer ist dieser Typ und
da fing es eigentlich an
er trat jahrelang auf Partys und in
Clubs auf bekam aber keinen
Plattenvertrag frustriert schlug er
einen anderen Weg ein
ich war von Anfang an gezwungen
Führungskraft zu sein denn ich musste
versuchen einen Vertrag zu bekommen
bekam aber kein ich ging zu jedem
einzelnen Plattenlabel und bekam keinen
Deal also hieß es entweder aufgeben und
zurück auf die Straße gehen oder mir
einen eigenen Weg schaffen um gehört zu
werden
1994 lernte Jay-Z Demon dashcam der
gerade erst im Künstlermanagement
angefangen hatte
Dash war damals ein junger Unternehmer
der vor allem Werbung für Partys machte
aber er managt da auch einzelne
Auftritte
der mendesch setzte große Hoffnung auf
den 24-Jährigen jasy sie gründeten ihr
eigenes Label Rockefeller Records mit
einer dritten Partnerin Corinne
dicksberg
sie druckten ihre eigenen CDs machten
Werbung packten Aufkleber an clubtüren
sie fuhren durch die Stadt und
verkauften die CDs aus dem Kofferraum
1995 wusste jeder in New York alles über
Hip Hop und wusste auch wer Jaycee war
Rockefeller hat es auf seine Weise
gemacht sie finanzierten ihre Videos
selbst auch viele ihrer Touren weil sie
wussten die mehr Geld Sie ausgeben
würden sie auch für sich behalten
es waren ihre Gewinne das war es was er
wollte sein Geschäft das Rockefeller wie
eine Kapitalgesellschaft führen
Rockefeller veröffentlichte jayz
Debütalbum reasonabout sie verkauften in
drei Monaten über 500.000 CDs
eine solide Grundlage um weiter zu
wachsen
sie waren sehr gut in dem was sie taten
sie machten eine super Promotion und die
Musik von Jaycee war so gut was er das
Wichtigste ist und dann ging es richtig
los und wurde zu dieser Underground
Sensation
trat auch ein Klassenkamerad von Jaycee
auf
Christopher Wallace alias Notorious BIG
die beiden Rapper aus Brooklyn traten
oft zusammen auf bis zum 9 März 97
in der Nacht wurde notorious in Los
Angeles von einem Unbekannten Attentäter
erschossen
Jay Z war erschüttert aber es war auch
der Moment in dem er der prominenteste
Rapper des Landes wurde
er war sehr traurig weil er ihm sehr
nahe gestanden hat aber gleichzeitig
wusste er dass es eine erstklassige
Gelegenheit war diese Lücke zu füllen
eine echte Stimme von der Straße eine
intelligente jazzys wachsendes ansehen
erregte die Aufmerksamkeit der
musikindustriegrößen Russell Simmons und
Leo Kohn und ihres Plattenlabels Def Jam
ich wollte Rockefeller in der Death
jam-familie haben einfach weil ich diese
Infrastruktur hatte
und ich brauchte wahnsinnig kreative
Leute um diese Infrastruktur zu nutzen
1997 kaufte Def Jam 50% von Rockefeller
Records für 1,5 Millionen Dollar
es war eine Partnerschaft 50/50 weshalb
wir ihn dabei das nächste Level zu
erreichen und es gab ihnen eine
Beteiligung und genau darum geht es bei
Jay Z und Beteiligung bei all seinen
Geschäften bekommt er immer etwas an dem
er festhalten kann
doch dann kam ein seltener Fehltritt das
Album in my life Band 1
[Musik]
you Düsseldorf
ich glaube das Problem war in my life
war kein besonders gutes Album Jessi
Klang plötzlich weicher um ein breiteres
Publikum zu erreichen
Hardcore Fans stellten seine
Glaubwürdigkeit in Frage
er sagte das Album sei ihm entglitten er
brauchte eine Wende und das schickte ihn
zurück in seine bewegte Vergangenheit
ich meine das Album war sein Thriller
das war sein Michael Jackson Thriller
Album
genau
das war sein erster Crossover Hit und
das annie-thema in den Kontext des
mercy-projekts zu stellen ist ziemlich
brillant und es hat funktioniert es war
eine riesen Erfolg
es schadet nicht dass er eine irrsinnige
Arbeitsmoral hat er hat wirklich sehr
sehr hart daran gearbeitet das zu
kreieren und zu promoten und es hat sich
gelohnt hartnock live brachte Jay Z 1999
einen Grammy für das beste Rap-Album ein
Jaycee der Superstar war wieder da
es braucht so viel um voranzukommen um
von einem Unbekannten zu einer
Berühmtheit zu werden
und ich denke er war bereit die Firma
war bereit und die Fans waren bereit
die 50 City-Tour für hartnoclife brachte
18 Millionen Dollar ein das Album
weitere 5 Millionen
Ende 99 gründeten Jaycee und seine
Partner das Modelabel rockerwear mit dem
sie in 18 Monaten 80 Millionen Dollar
Umsatz machen
er versuchte wie andere zu sein von Tiba
und Pickens oder Donald Trump sozusagen
am Ende ging es ihm darum irgendwo in
den Hamptons ein Haus zu haben und einen
Maybach zu fahren was er tatsächlich
auch Tat wissen Sie was ich meine
was auch immer der Erfolg ihm gebracht
haben mochte Frieden war es nicht sein
Temperament kam plötzlich und heftig
wieder an die Oberfläche es war etwas
das nicht hätte passieren dürfen und er
würde die als erster sagen dass es ein
schwerer Fehler war mit 29 war Jaycee
ein Hip Hop Superstar und Chef seines
eigenen Multimillionen Dollar
Unternehmens er hatte Jahre damit
verbracht sein Image zu pflegen
bis er am 1 Dezember 99 den Produzenten
Lance Rivera in KitKat Club in New York
mit einem Messerangriff
gut und vertraute ihn und als er von
angeblichen raumkopien hörte rammte er
ihm eine 3 Zoll Klänge in den Bauch
er hatte ihn gewarnt damit aufzuhören
und der Tat es nicht das alles in einem
Raum voller Zeugen er hatte alles zu
verlieren
wurde wegen Körperverletzung zweiten
Grades angeklagt er bekannte sich
schuldig und bekam drei Jahre auf
Bewährung
er hat fast alles durcheinander gebracht
aber er kam damit durch und sah aus als
wäre er der teflon-rapper der Teflon
Rapper lernte dann seine Diamanten Diva
Beyonce kennen
jahrelang vermieden Sie es über ihre
Beziehung zu sprechen
es hat lange gedauert bis er diese
Beziehung öffentlich bestätigt hat das
zeigt wie viel Angst der davor hatte zu
erkennen wie echt das war all dieses
Teflon musste entfernt und das Vertrauen
wieder aufgebaut werden sie ist die Frau
die in dieser Hinsicht das Unmögliche
geschafft hat
[Musik]
ich sein Privatleben beruhigte nahm sein
Geschäftsleben Fahrt auf mit mehr Hits
und Auszeichnungen
Ende 2001 erzielte seine Modelinie über
100 Millionen Dollar Umsatz
ein Jahr später machte Jay Z ein
schlagzeilenträchtiges Geschäft mit
Reebok
Steve Start von translation advertising
es gab noch nie einen Nicht-Sportler der
einen so großen schuhdeal mit einer der
drei Top-Marken abgeschlossen hatte Nike
Adidas Reebok wir verkauften innerhalb
einer Stunde 10.000 paar und dann bauten
wir 100 Millionen Dollar Franchise mit
dem Namen Skater auf
alles was er berührte schien Feuer zu
fangen
auch Beyoncé Solokarriere als er in
ihrer erfolgssinggle crazy in Love
auftrat
[Musik]
als ihr Album durchstartete schockierte
er seine Fans und verkündete seinen
Rückzug aus der Musik
weißt du ich bin zufrieden mit dem was
ich als Solo-Künstler erreicht habe ich
frage mich was könnte ich noch erreichen
ich glaube er wollte einfach für eine
Minute Abstand nehmen er hatte das
Gefühl alles getan zu haben was er tun
konnte
aber auf der anderen Seite wollte er
vielleicht auch sehen wie die Leute
darauf reagieren dass er in Rente geht
der größte Leben der Rapper
sein Abschiedskonzert fate to black im
November 2003 im Madison Square Garden
war sofort ausverkauft jetzt sollte das
Büro seine neue Bühne werden
[Musik]
in Tücher 2004 kaufte Def Jam die
restlichen Anteile an Rockefeller für 10
Millionen Dollar
sie gaben bekannt dass Jay Z Präsident
und Vorstand von Def Jam werden würde
mit einem Dreijahresvertrag im Wert von
weiteren 8 bis 10 Millionen Dollar
[Musik]
wenn man sich seine Vergangenheit
ansieht gibt es viele Leute die ihm als
Mentoren zur Seite gestanden haben er
lernte alles was sie ihm zu bieten
hatten und dann als er alles gelernt
hatte und er es nicht mehr brauchte ging
er weiter
[Musik]
bis Ende 2004 hatte rockerwear 300
Millionen Dollar eingespielt
für 30 Millionen Dollar und verkaufte
sie anderthalb Jahre später für 204
Millionen an den moderießen iconics
and Poing der Typ ist ein Genie und
jedes Mal wenn er einen Deal macht ist
der wahrscheinlich der klügste Typ im
Raum
im Hinterkopf denkt er weißt du ich habe
Geschäfte mit Leuten gemacht die viel
furchterregender sind als du er
beobachtet die Leute was sie tragen was
sie tun wie sie zucken wie sich ihr
Gesicht bewegt und dann wenn die Zeit
reif ist kommt er mit seiner Forderung
aber er fand noch eine weitere Rolle die
des Philanthropen anstatt nur Geld zu
verdienen begann er es zu verschenken
er gründete die schaumkater
stipendienstiftung für bedürftige
Studenten
2006 traf er sich mit Kofi anan bei der
UNO um auf eine Umweltkrise aufmerksam
zu machen die globale Wasserknappheit
alle 15 Sekunden steht dein Kind ich
freue mich sehr rauszugehen nicht nur
ein Rockstar zu sein sondern auch zu
helfen es hat ihn zu einem globalen
Botschafter gemacht seiner
Persönlichkeit eine neue Dimension
gegeben man kann ihn nicht mehr einfach
nur als Rapper bezeichnen
als Chef von Def Jam Records baute
Jaycee die Karrieren von Künstlern wie
Rihanna nio und Young jeesy aus und war
aber auch bereit für einen weiteren
eigenen Hit drei Jahre nach seinem
Rückzug veröffentlichte er Kingdom kam
das Album verkaufte sich in der ersten
Woche über 680.000 mal
2007 endete sein Vertrag bei Def Jam er
nahm die Rechte an seinen Aufnahmen mit
eine potenzielle Goldmine Josh Terry
ehemaliger Musikredakteur beim Time
Magazine und jetzt Redakteur der
Blumenberg Business
ich denke das Einzigartige an Jay Z als
Geschäftsmann ist dass er genau weiß wo
er sein will und nicht entgleist er ist
opportunistisch war aber von Anfang an
auch sehr strategisch
er glaubt dass ein Geschäft nicht
erfolgreich ist wenn die andere Seite
nicht auch gewinnt er ist ein
win-win-typ
vielleicht neigt er dazu selbst etwas
mehr zu gewinnen seine langfristige
Strategie umfasste eine Reihe lukrativer
Werbeverträge mit den konzerngiganten HP
Budweiser Heineken und Coke
er weiß sehr genau was er zu tun bereit
ist und was nicht er würde sein Image
seinen Namen und den guten Willen nie
für Geld für drehen oder Opfern jeder
wollte mit ihm Geschäfte machen
im April 2008 unterschrieb er beim
Konzert Giganten Live Nation einen
10-Jahresvertrag der Touren
Veröffentlichungen und Aufnahmen umfasst
als die Einnahmen der Plattenindustrie
rückläufig waren kam Live Nation mit
einem sogenannten 360 Deal auf Jason zu
was bedeutet dass sie ein Stück von
allem bekommen was er tut für Jay Z war
das brasiant denn während der Kuchen in
der Musikindustrie immer kleiner wurde
bot dieses Unternehmen einen viel
größeren Kuchen und garantierte
Einnahmen sie nahmen einen Teil des
Risikos und die Belohnung über viel
größer in derselben Woche besiegelte er
einen weiteren Deal die Presse stellte
fest dass er und Beyoncé verheiratet
waren
Jason wir anzeigen wenn Jay Z und
Beyoncé heiraten ist das als würden BMW
und Mercedes zusammen gehen das war die
stärkste Promi Marke der Welt
und dann die neue New Yorker
Nationalhymne die sie natra von seinem
Thron stieß
[Musik]
[Applaus]
das Album The Blueprints 3 schrieb
Musikgeschichte es war Jazz 11 Nummer 1
eine mehr als Elvis Presley der King
wurde von einem Hip-Hopper überholt
[Musik]
hat ist einfach bemerkenswert
es führte ihn wirklich aus dem Reich des
Hip-Hop und bringt ihn in die oberen
Ränge oder den höchsten Rang der
Popkultur er ist jetzt 40 Jahre alt er
könnte mit 50 Milliardär sein
wollte sich im Geschäft profilieren und
er wollte dass das noch lange nachwirkt
sein Ehrgeiz ist phänomenal und hat eine
wilde Geschwindigkeit
er ist schnell er ist wütend er wollte
schon lange ein Zeichen setzen das hat
diesen Kerl am Laufen gehalten
dass jemand der im Grunde eine Outlaw
Persönlichkeit war zum massenunterhalter
und Geschäftsmann wurde ist einfach eine
enorme Leistung
man hat ihnen das Orakel von Omaha
genannt den Weisen von Nebraska und
schon in jungen Jahren wusste er dass er
reich werden würde als ich zehn Jahre
alt war war mir klar dass mir nicht ein
langes Leben habe am Ende viel Geld
haben werde und hinter seinem
volkstümlichen auftreten verbirgt sich
einer der gewieftesten und härtesten
Geschäftsmänner Amerikas man macht keine
40 Milliarden Dollar indem man Mr Rogers
oder einer der Muppets ist Warren geht
über Leichen wenn es um eine Verhandlung
geht er nutzt jeden Hebel den er hat
Warren Buffett hat die risikoreichen
Spekulationen der Wall Street gemieden
er lebt und arbeitet in Omaha wo er 1930
geboren wurde und wo seine Besessenheit
von allen finanziellen Dingen begann ich
wusste dass ich mich für den Rest meines
Lebens für Aktien interessieren würde
schon als ich acht oder neun war ich
führte Tabellen über alle möglichen
Aktien
eine Tante schenkte mir einen Weltall
mal nach und so lernte ich die
Bevölkerungszahlen aller größeren Städte
auswendig ich mochte einfach Zahlen
nicht nur Wirtschaftszahlen
diese Zahlen zu merken sollte die
Grundlage für seinen späteren Erfolg
sein
Großvater hatte einen Lebensmittelladen
ich kaufte bei ihm Coca-Cola im
Sechserpack für einen Quarter und
verkaufte sie für einen Fünfer pro Stück
ich verkaufte Zeitungen am Türen ich
hatte alle möglichen kleinen Projekte
nicht alle sehr erfolgreich aber ich
machte von klein auf gern Geschäfte
mit 16 schrieb sich Buffett an der
Walton School der Universität von
Pennsylvania ein wo er mit Charles
Peterson zusammenwohnte jeden Tag nach
dem Unterricht verbrachte ich so viele
Stunden damit Krieg zu studieren ich
nahm die Bücher in die Hand und saß da
und blätterte Seite für Seite
und er konnte in ein paar Wochen zwei
oder drei Kurse durcharbeiten
er hatte ein fotografisches Gedächtnis
ich nicht
entdeckte auch früh seine Liebe zur
Politik ich war Präsident des Clubs der
jungen Republikaner an der Uni von
Pennsylvania und kandidierte sogar
einmal als Delegierter für den
landeskongress als Republikaner
nachdem er das College beendet hatte
machte Buffett einen Abschluss an der
Columbia Business School und kehrte nach
omacher zurück um sein eigenes
Unternehmen zu gründen er sagte ich
werde eine Gesellschaft gründen und er
fragte willst du mitmachen ich sagte
natürlich will ich zunächst waren wir
nur sieben oder acht Leute und noch
weitere Investoren zu überzeugen wurde
schon schwieriger eine Verkaufsgespräche
waren nicht sehr effektiv ich war 20
Jahre alt sah aus wie 16 und bemahmlich
wahrscheinlich wie ein zwölfjähriger ich
ging herum und sprach die Leute an sie
waren immer nett zu mir aber ich ging zu
irgendeinem Mann und erklärte ihm all
diese Fakten und Zahlen warum man Aktien
kaufen sollte und wenn ich dann mit
allem durch war zählte ich bis drei also
eins zwei drei und dann sagte der Mann
was sagt ihr Vater dazu ich hätte ihn
hauen können
es war frustrierend wusste dass er ein
besserer Verkäufer werden musste also
wandte er sich an den bekannten Mithilfe
Guru den Carnegie ich musste besser mit
Menschen kommunizieren vor allem in
Gruppen ich wusste einfach dass ich
diese Angst vor öffentlichen Auftritten
loswerden musste und ich hatte von
diesem Dale carnegie-kurs gehört ich
habe meiner Frau während dieses Kurses
an Heiratsantrag gemacht also ich bin
direkt auf meine Kosten gekommen jetzt
konnte Buffett endlich seine Karriere in
Gang bringen
er wählte Aktien aus die andere
ignorierten und seine Papiere stiegen
immer weiter nach und nach sprach sich
in Omaha herum dass der junge Mann
wusste was er tat
in den ersten fünf Jahren in denen
Buffett im Geschäft war stieg der DAU um
74 Prozent während Buffets Anlagen um
250% zulegen
1961 im Alter von 30 Jahren wurde er
Millionär
aber das sah man seiner Familie nicht an
ihr Haus in dem Buffet immer noch lebt
kaufte er vor über 50 Jahren für 32.000
Dollar seine Kinder gingen alle auf
öffentliche Schulen
Susi Buffett ist das Älteste von drei
Kindern
wir sind auf einer Art aufgewachsen die
wahrscheinlich anders ist als die da
meisten Kinder die einen Vater haben der
das hat was mein Vater hat sie haben
keine Autos bekommen als wir 16 waren
wir haben nicht wirklich anders gelebt
als die meisten anderen Kinder die wir
kannten
die größte Veränderung im
buffetthaushalt bestand darin dass
Warren sich vom Republikanismus seines
Vaters abwandte
die Bürgerrechte hatten den größten
Einfluss auf meiner Einstellung zur
Politik keine der beiden Parteien hat
sich unbedingt mit Ruhm bekleckert aber
die Demokraten schienen sich darauf viel
mehr einzustellen als die Republikaner
mit Anfang 30 wollte Warren Buffett
Unternehmen finden an denen er eine
Mehrheitsbeteiligung erwerben konnte und
interessant eines 100 Meilen entfernt in
Beatrice Nebraska
das war ein windmühlengeschäft tätig
Windmühlen sind ja heute wieder im
kommen aber vor 50 Jahren war das kein
gutes Geschäft die Aktien wurden sehr
billig gehandelt also kaufte ich welche
die ehemalige wallstreet-analystin alice
throwder ist die Autorin von der
Schneeball baffets autorisierte
Lebensgeschichte
es war ein Unternehmen das große
Lagerbestände aufgebaut hatte die es
nicht brauchte und die Belegschaft war
viel zu groß das Unternehmen musste
einfach verkleinert werden die Staat in
der es war war sehr klein und es war der
Hauptarbeitgeber
100 Menschen verloren ihren Job und
Buffett musste dafür gerade stehen was
wollen Buffett daraus gelernt hat ist
dass er sich nicht mehr in Unternehmen
einmischen wollte die Arbeitsprobleme
hatten in denen er Leute entlassen
musste in denen er sich persönlich in
das Management einmischen musste er
wollte dass jemand anderes das tut auch
das nächste große Investition sah nach
einem möglichen Misserfolg aus eine
Textilfabrik namens Berkshire Hathaway
deren Aktien für 7 Dollar und 50 Cent
verkauft wurden wir haben einen
Textilunternehmen gekauft das wie jedes
andere Textilunternehmen in New England
dazu bestimmt war irgendwann zu
verschwinden das war ein Fehler ist
geschäftsführender Gesellschafter von
Tito Partners
Unternehmen sie hatten keinen
Wettbewerbsvorteil der es ihnen
ermöglichte eine ausreichende Rendite zu
erwirtschaften sie waren zwar in
gewissem Maße profitabel aber diese
Rentabilität wurde unaufhaltsam kleiner
als das Geld aus Berkshire Hathaway
herausgezogen wurde wurde es
reinvestiert die erste große
Reinvestition die sehr profitabel war
war das Versicherungsgeschäft und das
trieb alles an was Berkshire Hathaway
von da an Tat
Andrew Frey ist Reporter bei Bloomberg
News
er verlagerte des Unternehmen also von
der Textil zur Versicherungsbranche zum
Teil deswegen weil die BR selbst Gewinne
abwarf aber auch weil Buffett die
Prämien die er von seinen
Versicherungsnehmern bekam wieder in
Aktien investieren konnte
das nennt man the float die
Versicherungsprämien bringen zinslos
Geld ein das dann in andere Unternehmen
investiert wird
Buffett fand auch einen Partner der
genauso marktkundig war wie er Charlie
Manga der als Anwalt arbeitete als die
beiden sich kennenlernten als ich Warren
kennenlernte erzählte er mir wie viel
besser seine Lebensweise sei und dass
sich zu klug sei um in einem so dummen
Geschäft wieder Anwaltspraxis zu
arbeiten während ich wie er eine
investitionspartnerschaft leiten könnte
und ich brauchte etwa zwei oder drei
Jahre um zu erkennen er hatte recht
in den späten 60er Jahren erlebte die
Wall Street einen beispiellosen Boom die
Kurse schossen hoch und jeder stürzte
sich in den Aktienmarkt aber für Waffe
war es an der Zeit auszusteigen
ich hatte etwas mehr als 100 Millionen
Dollar und viele glückliche Partner
und ich schrieb ihnen einen Brief ich
sagte ich weiß nicht mehr wie ich dieses
Spiel spielen soll die Bewertungen sind
so gestiegen dass ich nichts mehr finden
kann ich beendete meine Partnerschaft
es scheint nicht intuitiv zu sein aber
Warren hat immer Gas lui zitiert der
sagte sei gierig wenn andere ängstlich
sind sei ängstlich wenn andere gierig
sind und Warren wusste dass die Party
irgendwann zu Ende ist und die Blase
platzen wird
Buffett war 40 Jahre alt und über 25
Millionen Dollar schwer
aber er war unruhig und traf 1973 die
schicksalhafte Entscheidung sich in eine
kalifornische Bank
einzukaufen das Problem war Wesco befand
sich mitten in einem fusionsgeschäft mit
einem anderen Unternehmen und dann
beschwerte sich das Unternehmen das
Wesco kaufen wollte bei der
Börsenaufsichtsbehörde Warren würde
versuchen ihre Fusion zu verhindern was
illegal gewesen wäre daraufhin wurde
eine Untersuchung eingeleitet die
Börsenaufsicht untersuchte jeden Winkel
von Buffetts Geschäften und was sie
sagen alarmierte sie bafett und Mangas
Investitionen waren ein komplexes
Spinnennetz von Eigentum und
kreuzbeteiligungen wir waren da
hineingeraten weil wir mehrere
Unternehmen hatten das Ganze sah aus wie
eine Menge Spaghetti das für irgendeinen
bösen Zweck gemacht worden war
wir haben nicht das Gefühl dass wir
etwas Verbotenes getan hatten aber es
gab viele Regeln und die Frage ob wir
gegen welche verstoßen hatten
Stanleys Borken war
vollstreckungsdirektor bei der
Börsenaufsicht
immer wenn man feststellt dass Dinge so
verdrahtet sind dass es lange dauert bis
man sie versteht Stellen kommt der
Verdacht auf dass jemand das vielleicht
tut um mit etwas davon zu kommen
was die Ermittler ebenfalls stutzig
machte war die Tatsache dass Manga und
Buffett den Aktionären an der Westküste
einen höheren Preis für ihre Aktien
anboten als sie auf dem freien Markt
erzielen konnten also kauften wir
einfach weiter bis unser Kontingent
erschöpft war und zwar um zwei oder drei
Punkte höher als wir mussten das war
zwar sehr eigenwillig aber wir hielten
es für das Richtige und die
Börsenaufsicht drehte durch
um eine Katastrophe abzuwenden wandte
sich Buffets Anwalt mit einem
unorthodoxen Appell an Stanley spocking
er sagte sie mal stand auch wenn das in
deinen Augen nicht gut aussieht möchte
ich dass du dir den Charakter dieser
Person anguckst in meiner Meinung nach
wird er wahrscheinlich die Nummer eins
der finanzdienstleistungsbr in aller
Zeiten in einem Restaurant
wir Appell hatte Erfolg Buffets
Unternehmen wurde zu einer
hunderttausend Dollar Strafe verurteilt
aber es wurde keine Anklage gegen
Buffett erhoben
[Musik]
der Aktienkurs von Berkshire Hathaway
stieg auf 93 Dollar
wobei die Gewinne vor allem auf das
Versicherungsgeschäft zurückzuführen
waren Bafög hatte auch Anteile an Banken
kleiderherstellern und Süßwaren Fabriken
aber bei einem Unternehmen war er
besonders leidenschaftlich ich liebe
Zeitungen ich habe angefangen zu lesen
wissen sie mein Vater brachte sie mit
nach Hause ich weiß nicht ob ich sechs
oder sieben oder acht war aber es war
das erste was ich mir schnappte meine
Schwestern auch
sein erster zeitungskauf war ein Omaha
Wochenblatt namens The Sun die Zeitung
gewann einen Pulitzerpreis eine seltene
Auszeichnung für ein kleines Blatt
dann begann er Aktien der Washington
postcompany zu kaufen die Zeitung war
nach dem Watergate-Skandal finanziell
angeschlagen
[Musik]
1973 waren die Aktien starke fallen auch
weil die nächsten Regierungen der
Washington Post sozusagen den Krieg
erklärt hatte
[Applaus]
das Interessante ist als wir diesen
Stapel für 20 Dollar die Aktie kauften
wenn man die Leute die sie uns
verkauften gefragt hätte wie viel das
Unternehmen eigentlich wert ist hätten
sie gesagt 100 $ pro Aktie und sie haben
trotzdem verkauft ich bin der nächsten
Regierung auf ewig dankbar dass sie
damals den Staub aufgewirbelt hat
buffett hatte sich immer von den
Führungskräften seines Unternehmens
ferngehalten
aber das war bei der Washington Post
nicht der Fall wo die Verlegerin
Katherine Graham seine
gesellschaftspartnerin und vertraute
wurde
[Musik]
sie Bahn einer Branche tätig die mich
faszinierte mich zu verschiedenen Partys
in Washington ein die sehr interessant
waren ich sah Teile der Welt die ich
sonst nicht gesehen hätte wenn wir nicht
Freunde geworden werden
aber während sich Buffets
gesellschaftlicher Kreis erweiterte
fühlte sich seine Frau Susi zu Hause
zunehmend isoliert und traf eine
Entscheidung sie ließ sich nicht von
Warren scheiden sondern ging nach San
Francisco Cisco um ein neues Leben zu
beginnen ich verstehe warum sie
umgezogen ist mein Vater wurde immer
berühmter und meine Mutter war so gar
nicht der misses Warren Buffett Typ ihre
Beziehung hat sich nie verändert sie
waren total verliebt haben fünf sechs
sieben acht Mal am Tag miteinander
gesprochen sind zusammen verreist sie
konnte bloß einfach nicht hier leben
um sicherzustellen dass Warren in ihrer
Abwesenheit versorgt war wandte sich
Susi an ihre Freundin Astrid Mengs nach
ein paar Monaten zog Astrid ein es ist
sehr unortedox eine Menge Leute haben
sicher darüber geredet und alle
möglichen netten Sachen darüber gesagt
wie seltsam das sei aber ich denke mir
weißt du was es geht niemanden was an
was in der Beziehung anderer passiert es
hat für die drei funktioniert es hat
funktioniert Buffett ging in die
Geschichte rein als er bei der Übernahme
der American broadcasting company durch
capital city half dem bis dahin größten
Medien Deal aber sein goldenes Händchen
reichte nicht aus als Buffett 700
Millionen Dollar in Solomon Brothers
investierte dem damals größten
Investmenthaus einige Jahre später
geriet Salomon in große Schwierigkeiten
gardente big trouble es wurde brenzlig
als ich im August 91 einen Anruf bekam
man deutete mir an welche Probleme auf
mich zukamen ein Händler namens moscher
hatte einige sehr schlimme Dinge auf dem
us-staatsanleihenmarkt getan
zu diesen schlimmen Dingen gehörten
illegale Handlungen dieses
solomon-händlers der den anleiemarkt
durch den Einsatz nicht genehmigter
konnten in die Enge trieb um den Anteil
von Solomon zu erhöhen und die
Konkurrenten zu verdrängen Derek morn
war stellvertretender Vorsitzender bei
Solomon Brothers er war entsetzt über
das was
geschahen mir war klar dass wir gegen
das Gesetz verstoßen haben wir hatten
uns in die Funktion eines wichtigen
Marktes eingemischt und die Zentralbank
wäre nicht begeistert
als Chef von Salomon Brothers nahmen
John good friend die Schuld für das
Chaos auf sich
ich erinnere mich lebhaft daran wenn man
es auf die Titelseite der New York Times
schafft mit Bild aber ein Dummkopf ist
das mach ich wohl da wurde meine Notlage
landesweit bekannt das war
wahrscheinlich einer der schlimmsten
Tage meines Lebens
ich sagte Tom Strauss und John marry
Weber
Street wird gemunkelt dass die Spitze
von Solomon ihren Rücktritt angeboten
hat um einen Ausschluss des Unternehmens
als Haupthändler für Staatsanleihen zu
verhindern
unternahm einen letzten verzweifelten
Versuch das Unternehmen zu retten indem
er in Omaha anrief und Buffett bat den
Chefposten zu übernehmen
ich hielt mich da raus um eine reine
Weste zu behalten wir hofften dass ich
das Vertrauen der Leute gewinnen würde
die wütend auf uns waren und davon gab
es jede Menge
die Krise verschärfte sich als
Finanzminister Nikolas Brady anordnete
das solle man aus dem anleihergeschäft
aussteigt
es wurde an einem Sonntagmorgen bekannt
gegeben dass das US-Finanzministerium
uns von der Liste der wirklich
akzeptablen Leute der primärhändler
gestrichen hatte das wäre der Todesstoß
gewesen also musste ich was tun und zwar
bis zum Handelsstart in Tokio
das war eine nationale Katastrophe
gewesen und es sah lange Zeit so aus als
würde die Regierung einfach sagen zum
Teufel mit dir Solomon
Bafög verbrachte den ganzen Tag mit
verzweifelten Telefonaten nach
Washington um die Regierung zum Rückzug
zu bewegen ich war zu Tode erschrocken
und es hörte man mir wahrscheinlich auch
an viele Leute wollten dass wir an
diesem Wochenende das Geschäft aufgeben
und ich wusste nicht was passieren würde
gegen 23 Uhr gab Minister Brady Solomon
noch eine Chance um das Geschäft zu
besiegeln musste Buffett persönlich bei
Solomon aufräumen
es war ein Elend ich war neun Monate und
vier Tage dort und es ist kein Zufall
dass ich 20 Jahre später genau sagen
kann wie lange ich dort war aber es war
wichtig das zu erledigen ich würde
niemanden wünschen was mit der Firma
passiert ist aber in gewisser Weise habe
ich viel gelernt
wurde zum Helden
Warren Buffett trifft sich mit der
Finanzgemeinde gibt Autogramme sie
lieben ihn der Mann mit dem
blitzsauberen Image der versucht das
Chaos bei Solomon Brothers zu beseitigen
1993 erreichte der Aktienkurs von
Berkshire Hathaway 17.000 Dollar und
Buffett weltberühmt aber keine noch so
große Weltreise konnte Buffets
Gewohnheiten ändern lasst uns über
warrence Ernährung sprechen hier ist das
Gemüse dass er ist
am Kolben Pommes Kartoffelpuffer und das
Obst wäre
bananencremetorte Erdbeerkuchen
ich glaube das war schon an Obst er
trinkt auch mehrere kirsch-cola am Tag
ich habe den Mann noch nie in meinem
Leben und das ist kein Witz einen
Schluck Wasser trinken sehen niemals
die 90er und 2000er Jahre waren die Zeit
der größten Expansion von Berkshire
Hathaway experience das Unternehmen
holte sich das größte Möbelhaus des
Landes
einen führenden Hersteller von
Wohnmobilen Fruit of the Loom Underwear
Benjamin Moore paints Derry Queen gaiko
in schulens insgesamt über 70
Unternehmen mit 250.000 Beschäftigten
einige Investitionen erschienen
unkonventionell
er kaufte die Zeitung seiner Heimatstadt
den Omaha world Harald und die
Eisenbahngesellschaft berlintin northern
Ray Road das ist es was Warren Buffett
immer wieder gemacht hat wenn er in
etwas investiert dann schaut jeder drauf
und sagt ich habe es doch gesehen warum
habe ich das nicht gleich erkannt
in Omaha wurde die
Jahreshauptversammlung von Berkshire
Hathaway zu einer Pilgerstätte für
zehntausende von Aktionären was ist
wirklich erstaunlich das Stadion ist
voll und die Scheinwerfer sind auf
kleinen Klapptisch gerichtet an dem
280-jährige sitzen und diese beiden
80-jährigen haben mehr Ausdauer als alle
anderen im Raum
von Freitag bis Sonntagabend ist er
nonstop unterwegs und je länger das
Wochenende dauert desto mehr Energie hat
er
ich kann es nicht erklären es muss an
den Bürgern liegen
in den 2000er Jahren war Buffett zig
Milliarden Dollar wert
Geld dass er an eine Stiftung geben
wollte wie seine Frau Susi leiten sollte
doch 2004 starb Susi an einem
Schlaganfall nach einer Krebsoperation
es war ein großer Schock für uns alle
mein Vater ich kann nicht erklären wie
sehr er sie geliebt hat und wie sehr er
sich auf sie verlassen hat ich fange an
zu weinen wenn ich darüber rede
wissen sie er wird nie ganz darüber
hinwegkommen keiner von uns wird das
wahrscheinlich sie war wirklich etwas
ganz Besonderes
zwei Jahre nach dem Tod seiner Frau
heiratete Buffett Astrid Mengs bei einer
privaten Feier und gab bekannt dass er
den Großteil seines Vermögens nicht
seinen Kindern sondern der Stiftung von
Bill und Melinda Gates vermacht Bill
Gates ist seit den frühen 90er Jahren
einer von Buffets engsten Freunden
es war phänomenal wir konnten viel
ehrgeiziger an viele Dinge rangehen die
wir sonst nicht hätten tun können
es ist jedes Jahr ein gigantisches
Geschenk mit dem wir doppelt so
erfolgreich sein können wie wir es ohne
je gewesen wären
[Musik]
Bafög war einer berühmte Persönlichkeit
und ein brillanter Geschäftsmann
als die US-amerikanische Wirtschaft 2008
in die Krise geriet war bafet erneut der
Retter vieler Finanzinstitute die unter
den Schulden Bergen zusammenbrachen
der darmschloss am Montag mit einem
Minus von mehr als 500 Punkten
[Musik]
ist ein riesiges Gütesiegel für gute
Haushaltsführung wenn er Geld in eine
Sache steckt kann man davon ausgehen
dass er klug genug ist diese Investition
zu tätigen weil er glaubt dass er damit
eine gute Rendite erzielen wird und das
beruhigt die Leute wenn die Angst am
größten ist
zu den Unternehmen die von Warren
Buffett unterstützt wurden gehörten
Goldman Sex ge und später die Bank of
America aber inzwischen ist Bafög über
80 und es bleibt die Frage wer wird der
Nachfolger dieser finanz-ikone an der
Spitze von Berkshire Hathaway es wurde
bereits jemand gefunden aber sein Name
noch nicht veröffentlicht bin
make-public
jedoch verrät sind die politischen und
wirtschaftlichen Anliegen die ihm am
Herzen liegen
ich glaube in den letzten Jahren hatte
einige Sachen gesehen wo er dachte wenn
ich den Mund aufmache könnte das etwas
bewirkens was er am lautesten anspricht
sind die Ungerechtigkeiten des
Steuersystems tagsystem etwas das als
buffet-regel bekannt wurde es gibt alle
möglichen Superreichen die normale
Steuern zahlen aber es gibt eine kleine
Gruppe die man sehr leicht finden kann
die sehr niedrige Steuern zahlt mich
angeschlossen
er schätzt sich glücklich zu diesem
Zeitpunkt der Geschichte in Amerika
geboren worden zu sein
ich glaube er ist einer der
eindrucksvollsten friedlichsten Menschen
die ich je getroffen habe er hat mit dem
was er getan hat viel bewegt und jeder
mit dem er zu tun hatte hat damit Geld
verdient und sein Leben verbessert
es gibt wirklich niemanden wie Warren
wir sollten uns zurücklehnen und von den
tiefgründigen Überlegungen profitieren
die er seit seiner Jugend über die
Wirtschaft angestellt hat
ich habe einfach jeden Tag eine tolle
Zeit ich meine ich fange an genau das zu
tun was ich im Leben tun will besser
geht's nicht
er ist rücksichtslos hartnäckig genial
Genius ein medienmagnat der ein globales
Imperium im Wert von mehr als 80
Milliarden Dollar Schuff er liebt das
Mediengeschäft er ist 24 Stunden am Tag
sieben Tage die Woche damit beschäftigt
er ist schläft und trinkt es Erfolg in
den Medien kommt nicht so leicht und
schnell
Rupert maddock von News Korb ist ein
moderner pressebaron Herrscher über
Zeitungen und Zeitschriften
Fernsehsender und Kabelkanäle
Filmstudios und Satellitensysteme die
oft die Botschaft ihres provokanten und
polarisierenden Chefs widerspiegeln
seine Redakteure wissen was Rupert will
und setzen das auch gerne um seit mehr
als 50 Jahren baut Murdock sein Reich
Stück für Stück auf und löst dabei
Feuerstürme der kontroversen aus Rupert
murdok ist die Verkörperung des Bösen
ist nicht mehr die angesehene Zeitung
die sie einmal war und entfacht bittere
Rivalitäten
es ist ein zeitungskrieg es gibt immer
jemanden der sterben muss damit du leben
kannst und Rupert ist gut darin weil er
mehr Schmerz ertragen kann als jeder
andere
diese Kämpfe führten sein Unternehmen
von den Höhen des Erfolgs um den Rande
des Zusammenbruchs und wieder zurück
man könnte fast sagen er ist
größenwahnsinnig er will so viel
besitzen so viel Einfluss haben wie er
kann er will der größte und beste sein
den es je gab oder geben wird
maddock wurde schon als vieles
bezeichnet sogar in seinem eigenen
Netzwerk ich bin Rupert Mörder der
tyrannische Milliardär und das ist meine
Skybox wenn du Rupert Murdock bist
beweise es
[Musik]
madox-präsenz im Film Fernsehen und
Printmedien ist in fast allen Teilen der
Welt zu spüren
Rupert murdok ist das was Gott meinte
als er einen Medienmanager schuf er hat
alle Eigenschaften die ein Medienmanager
braucht hier er hat Visionen er hat Mut
er geht Risiken ein und er geht an die
Grenzen
sein Imperium startete mit seiner
kleinen Zeitung in Australien und wurde
zu einem der größten Medienunternehmen
der Welt mit über 150 Zeitungen
internationalen Fernsehsendern und einem
Filmstudio Studio die News Corporation
hat einen jährlichen Umsatz von etwa 32
Milliarden Dollar der Mann der so viel
von dem kontrolliert was wir sehen
wollte nicht von uns interviewt werden
obwohl er seine politischen Ansichten
nie versteckt hat ich würde sagen
unterstützt die buschpolitik im Nahen
Osten auch wenn wir sein Vorgehen sehr
kritisch gesehen haben
oder seine Ambitionen extrem
rücksichtslos er wusste was er wollte
und nichts würde ihn davon abhalten das
zu bekommen und ich glaube das war
wahrscheinlich sein ganzes Leben lang
seinen Markenzeichen der Anfang und der
Kern seines Imperiums die Zeitung
Michael Wolf ist der Autor von the man
who und the news dieser Mann ist im
Zeitungsgeschäft aufgewachsen er hat
darin Erfolg gefunden er liebt das
Zeitungsgeschäft ich habe Ihnen eine
Zeitung lesen sehen das ist ein
körperlicher Akt es ist so körperlich
wie mit einer Frau Liebe zu machen
diese Besessenheit lag in seinen Genen
Rupert Mörder wurde am 11 märz 1931 als
Sohn des prominenten zeitungsmannes
circlees Mörder und seiner Frau Lady
Elizabeth murdog geboren er wuchs auf
der Familienfarm außerhalb von Melbourne
Australien auf und besuchte das
exklusive Internat g-long
ich weiß nicht ob es mir gefallen hat
oder nicht ich habe damals nicht darüber
nachgedacht aber die meisten
Erinnerungen sind sicherlich glücklich
aber er fühlte sich fehl am Platz
umgeben von den Kindern der Melbourner
Elite Andrew Butcher war Vizepräsident
für unternehmensangelegenheiten und
Kommunikation bei newscore
aus einem privilegierten Umfeld aber
sein Vater besaß das Unternehmen nicht
indem er arbeitete er leitete es Rupert
sah sich selbst immer als Außenseiter er
blühte darin auf es gab ihm ein
Wettbewerbsvorteil
erhob sich noch weiter ab als er nach
Oxford ging wo seine Vorliebe für die
kommunistische Philosophie ihm einen
Spitznamen einbrachte der rote Rupert
das war wohl das Produkt seines
rebellischen Geistes ich bin sicher dass
er gegen seine Eltern rebellierte wo er
konnte und gegen die Werte seiner Eltern
so wie die meisten jungen Leute
Mango McKellen war ein junger Journalist
in Australien der später mit Murdock
zusammenarbeitete ich glaube das vor
allem von dem Wunsch getrieben war dem
Ruf seines Vaters gerecht zu werden
es war eine angespannte Erziehung sein
Vater war ziemlich distanziert es war
schwer was freundliches aus ihm
herauszubekommen
Zuneigung zu seinem Vater und zu dem was
er erreicht hat
entschlossen in stolz zu machen welches
oktober 1952 als er an Oxford studierte
erfuhr murder das sein Vater im Alter
von 67 Jahren an Krebs und Herzproblemen
gestorben war als er nach Hause
zurückkehrte sah er wie seine Mutter von
dem Kollegen seines Vaters unter Druck
gesetzt wurde ihre zeitungsbeteiligungen
zu verkaufen Rupert war entsetzt wie
seine Mutter behandelt wurde und über
den Mangel an Respekt gegenüber sein
Vater stattdessen Tod vom Verkauf
bedrohter unter anderem die Adelaide
News ein Boulevard mit einer Auflage von
nur 75.000
nach seinem Abschluss in Oxford ging
murdok zurück nach Australien und
übernahm die Kontrolle
schon bald hatte er seine Finger in
allen Unternehmensbereichen
[Musik]
ich weiß was eigener Erfahrung dass er
die gleichen redaktionellen Fähigkeiten
hatte wie alle anderen
1958 machte er seinen ersten Vorstoß in
ein anderes Medium das Fernsehen mit
Channel nein einem kleinen lokalen
Sender Peter Turnen ist ehemaliger
Präsident und Chief Operating Officer
danius Corporation
ich glaube eines der Dinge an die sich
die Leute nicht erinnern ist das Rupert
schon Ende der 50er Anfang der 60er
Jahre in Australien an fernsehnetzwerk
besaß und das ist eines der Dinge die
ihn hierher brachten er hatte
wiederholungsrechte und Filmrechte von
amerikanischen Studios und Netzwerken
gekauft
der Wert des Senders stiegt
kaufte bald eine Reihe von
Lokalzeitungen auf darunter den Daily
Mirror ein beliebtes Boulevardblatt in
Sydney
aber murdox ziel war es eine nationale
Zeitung zu gründen
1964 startete er sie Australian
man sagte ihnen das werde nicht
funktionieren die Entfernung sei zu groß
und es gäbe nicht genug nationale
Werbungen um das Blatt aufrecht zu
erhalten man sagte ihnen er wäre auch
kein Personal finden weil kein guter
Journalist für eine Zeitung arbeiten
wolle die so eindeutig zum Scheitern
verurteilt sei
die Zeitung hatte von Anfang an eine
liberale Haltung und der verantwortliche
Mann war immer präsent
Rupert lief praktisch jeden Abend im
Büro auf und ab er ging dann spät abends
um 22 Uhr gegen Redaktionsschluss in der
Zeitung herum meistens in so einem
Leuchten gelben Regenmantel und wurde
gelegentlich von einem der Mitarbeiter
die ihm nicht so gut kannten mit einer
Reinigungskraft verwechselt
Maddox direkte Kontrolle über seine
Zeitungen hat sich früh durchgesetzt
ich mische mich schon sehr in die
Zeitungen ein aber ich glaube
andererseits lasse ich meinen
Redakteuren auch große Freiheiten im
Alter von 25 Jahren heiratete murdok und
bekam eine Tochter pro Dance die Ehe
wurde nach elf Jahren geschieden
1967 heiratete er seine zweite Frau Emma
torff mit ihr bekam er in den nächsten
fünf Jahren drei Kinder Elizabeth
lachlen und James
ist seine Familie und seine Firma ich
glaube das sind diese Dinge die in
seinem Kopf absolut miteinander
verbunden sind mit dem Alter wurden
seine Ansichten konservativer
wurde mehr und mehr zum Gefangenen der
Geschäftswelt in Sydney
und wenn er in den Yachtclub ging
machten sich die anderen immer über ihn
lustig und fragten na wie geht's deinem
roten Lappen von der Zeitung Rupert
Rupert ist glaube ich vor allem an Macht
interessiert man könnte fast sagen er
ist größenwahnsinnig er möchte so viel
wie möglich besitzen so viel wie möglich
beeinflussen der größte und beste sein
den es je gab geben wird
Ende der 60er Jahre war Rupert murdok
auf einem anderen Kontinent gelandet in
einem der
wettbewerbsintensivstenmärkte der Welt
der Definition des alten
establishmentsreet
wo er auf den berüchtigten
medienmagnarten robert Maxwell steht
es wurde murdox David gegen Maxwells
Goliath
Murdock fing an gegen seine bekannten
Konkurrenten in den Kampf zu ziehen
man kann Rupert Geschäftsstrategie als
zeitungsstrategie betrachten es ist ein
zeitungskrieg es gibt immer jemanden der
sterben muss damit man leben kann
mit einem Doppelschlag überlistete er
Maxwell und kaufte die beliebte und
klatschsüchtige News of the World und
die schwächelnde Tageszeitung The Suns
baute sie in kürzester Zeit zu einem
Kraftwerk auf
die Leser waren vor allem Männer die
eine Kombination wollten aus Sport Sex
Skandalen ein bisschen Politik und oben
ohne Mädchen
Charlie Beckett ist medienanalyst an der
landen School of Economics
ob man sie nun mag oder nicht und
Millionen von Menschen liebten sie hat
einen riesigen kulturellen Einfluss
gehabt sowohl zum guten als auch zum
Bösen sie hatte einen Stil der die
Öffentlichkeit für sehr reale Themen
sensibilisiert hat und sie war natürlich
ein fantastischer kommerzieller Erfolg
jetzt hatte murdok eine neue Welt im
Visier die ihr erobern wollte Amerika
oder auch nicht in Großbritannien aber
er kam hier an und dachte sofort dass es
mein Zuhause
1973 ließ sich murdok mit seiner Familie
in der wohlhabenden Upper Eastside in
New York nieder
er wollte expandieren aber um auf dem
US-Markt Fuß zu fassen musste er sich
mit einer kleinen Regionalzeitung
zufriedengeben
kann sie zu kaufen
als nächstes wollte murdok eine
nationale Präsenz also gründete er eine
Zeitung the star um gegen den
reißerischen national enquirement
doch der Star hatte es schwer zu
scheinen
Boulevardzeitungen werden in Amerika ein
Supermärkten verkauft das heißt Sie
müssen für Frauen sein nicht für Männer
das war nie ein richtig erfolgreiches
Experiment
trotzdem verkaufte er später einen
aufgepeppten Star für 400 Millionen
Dollar an die Muttergesellschaft des
National enquira
doch dann war es ein verblassenes
liberales Boulevardblatt das seine
Fantasie beflügelte die New York Post
die er 1976 für 30 Millionen Dollar
kaufte
wenig später erwarb er gegen den
Widerstand der Arbeitnehmer das New York
Magazine für 7,5 Millionen Dollar
inklusive der Liberalen village voice
es ist schwer sich eine Publikation
vorzustellen die weniger zu Rupert
Mörder passt als die Village voice
die Voice warf einen ansehnlichen Gewinn
ab 8 Jahre später verkaufte murdoxy für
55 Millionen Dollar
murdog war jetzt auf den Plan in New
York im Januar 77 schmückte er das
Titelblatt des Timer gesehens als King
Kong der über der Stadt thront und nach
den einflussreichsten Blättern greift
darunter auch die Post
Martin singerman ist ehemaliger
Herausgeber der New York Post die
Zeitung lag im sterben wenn man so will
Rupert murdok investierte in das Blatt
sowohl finanziell als auch personell
in people anderthalb Jahre später
investierten wir in neudruckmaschinen um
der Zeitung Farbe zu geben
fügten Seiten hinzu und machten alles
was man tun würde um der Zeitung mehr
Substanz zu geben
murdox instinct belebte die Zeitung mit
aufsehenerregendem Schlagzeilen der
Inhalt Nachrichten kombiniert mit
Klatsch und Tratsch Sport Horoskopen und
spielen
Zeitungen verkaufen sich über
Schlagzeilen aber langfristig müssen sie
auch Substanz haben die Leute kaufen Sie
nicht wenn Sie sie einmal angeschaut
haben und nichts finden es ist also
wirklich ein zweistufiger Prozess
die Post wurde sehr beliebt
auch finanziell war sie eine Katastrophe
und verlor jedes Jahr Millionen von
Dollar
Wirtschaftsjournalist Ron growser
ich glaube nicht dass es Rupert unter
dem Strich nur darum geht zu gewinnen
ihm gefällt der Gedanke dass er dadurch
einen Platz am Tisch bekommt dass er
seine Position nach außen tragen kann
dass er Zugang zu Politikern bekommt
1980 war Rupert murdog ein wichtiger
Akteur in der New Yorker Medienszene
er beteuerte seinen Redakteuren große
Freiheiten einzuräumen aber diese
Botschaft kam nicht immer bei den
Mitarbeitern an Rupert schrieb
Schlagzeilen Rupert machte die Stories
Rupert diktierte die Geschichten Rupert
war einfach überall
jemand sagte zu ihm Mister Murdock da
gibt es einen Widerspruch sie sagten
dass sie ihren Redakteuren erlauben die
Zeitung zu leiten und er sagte das ist
kein Widerspruch ich kenne bloß die
Redakteure die ich einstelle
es gibt Rupert und dann gibt es die
Leute unter ihm er stellt gern Leute ein
die ihm dankbar dafür sind dass er sie
eingestellt hat solche auf deren
Loyalität erzählen kann stellt nicht
gerne Leute ein die mit ihm konkurrieren
könnten die das Gefühl haben könnten
dass sie auf der gleichen Ebene stehen
wie er denen
die Kontrolle die er über seine
Nachrichten Organisationen ausübt
besteht nicht wirklich daran dass er ins
Telefon schreit
man hat eher das Gefühl dass seine
Redakteure wissen was er will und dass
sie das gerne umsetzen
[Musik]
zeigte sich schon bald in einer
jahrzehntelangen kaufroorgie
1981 kaufte er die angesehene times und
die sunday-times in London zurück in den
Staaten holte er sich den Boston Harris
und die Chicago sometimes und wurde
erneut mit einer Revolte empfangt vier
Top-Manager der Sun times haben ihren
Rücktritt erklärt darunter Verleger
James Hall und der Kolumnist mike rojko
hat sich beurlauben lassen
ich würde nie für so eine Zeitung
Arbeiten nicht in New York nicht in
Washington nicht in sein Antonio das ist
Schuld
nichts davon störte murder und es bliebt
nicht bei Zeitungen in 1985 kaufte
twenty Century Fox ein Geschäft von
zentraler Bedeutung denn es ist ein
Crossover hier ist ein Mann der im
Verlagswesen tätig ist und jetzt ein
Filmstudio kauft
er zahlte dem ex-elmann Marvin Davis 250
Millionen für eine 50-prozentige
Beteiligung an dem Studio
es war schwierig die ersten 50% von
Davis zu kriegen aber dann bekam er die
anderen 50% für schlappe 325 Millionen
Dollar
und so Übernahme das gesamte Filmstudio
24 Century Fox eine multimillian-schwere
Anlage für knapp eine halbe Milliarde
Dollar
er hat mir mal gesagt dass die Filme der
Nervenkitzel sind man braucht die
Nervenkitzel wenn man den Rest des
Medienimperiums schon hat er braucht sie
weil auf diese Weise kreative Leute in
das Unternehmen kommen der Kitzel könnte
auch nachlassen vor allem im riskanten
Multimillionen Dollar Filmgeschäft movie
business
eines der großartigsten Dinge an Rupert
ist dass er in einer Krise der coolste
und ruhigste ist und wenn er dich
unterstützt und hat dich glaubt wird er
immer hinter dir stehen
weißt du wenn er an Dich glaubt und du
ehrlich zu ihm bist und ihn von der
Angemessenheit deiner Entscheidung
überzeugt ist er der beste Mann den du
dir in einem Schützengraben wünschen
kannst
sein Unternehmen erweitern indem er sich
in den us-fernsehmarkt einkaufte aber da
gab es ein ernsthaftes Problem es gibt
eine Vorschrift dass man Staatsbürger
der Vereinigten Staaten sein muss um
einen Fernsehsender zu besitzen und
Rupert der Prag beschloss wenn das nötig
ist werde ich eben US-Bürger am 4
September 85 wurde Rupert murdog
amerikanischer Staatsbürger
ist ehemaliger Vorstandsvorsitzender von
British Airways und ein enger
freundische Staatsbürgerschaft aufgab um
die amerikanische aufzunehmen wurde er
dafür kritisiert aber das Unternehmen
war nun mal dort und der größte Markt
ist in den USA es ist nicht so dass er
die amerikanische Staatsbürgerschaft nur
angenommen hat um dort ein medienbaron
zu sein er hat sich entschieden sein
Leben in Amerika zu verbringen
murdok hatte einen Masterplan er
bezahlte John kloby von metromedia bis
zu zwei Milliarden Dollar um
Fernsehsender in sechs großen Märkten zu
kaufen
sie bildeten den Kern dessen was Fox
television Natur werden sollte
es gab
es und es gab keinen Platz für ein
weiteres Netzwerk und dann kommt ruperta
her und startet ein viertes Netzwerk
[Musik]
das ist ein großen Spielraum für ein
Netzwerk gab das jüngere Zuschauer
anzieht und eine größere Vielfalt an
Zuschauern aber aus dem hochkarätigen
Debüt wurde ein schwerer Fehlschlag
das ist die Piep Taste wir gehen live
drauf und das heißt kein Piep die Late
Show mit Joan Rivers scheiterte kläglich
gegen den unerschütterlichen Johnny
Carson für das junge Team bei Fox eine
bittere Lektion Gareth Enzians der
ehemalige Präsident des Fernsehsenders
seit den 50er Jahren hatte niemand mehr
eine sendekette gegründet wir mussten
erstmal herausfinden wie ein Network
sein muss dass sich von NBC ABC und CBS
unterscheidet im Nachhinein scheint es
offensichtlich oh ja wenn du sendest
wenn CBS sendet dann wirst du keinen
Erfolg haben
Fox machte sich daran Top-Talente zu
gewinnen wie die Serienschöpfer James
Brooks und Stephen kennen es gab
kreative Freiheit und sicherlich mehr
als sie bei den anderen Networks
bekommen würden aber wir gaben auch
größere Aufträge wir setzen direkt auf
Serien weil wir das mussten wir hatten
ja nur ein Jahr Zeit um das Ganze
aufzubauen und zum Laufen zu bringen
mit einer Reihe von Sendungen die sich
gegen die Konkurrenz durchsetzen begann
der vierte Sender sich in den
Einschaltquoten zu behaupten
[Musik]
twenty one Jump Street young kopfshow
Mary children irre Veron family Show ich
meine der Arbeitstitel von Mary children
war nicht die cosbys und living color
und all diese Dinge wurden viel mehr es
muss einfach anders sein als die Sachen
auf den anderen Kanälen und nichts war
so anders wie die Sendung die alles
verändern sollte der größte Wendepunkt
waren die Simpsons
Rupert hat es über alles geliebt den
Sendeplan zu erstellen er war wie ein
Kind in einem Süßwarenladen und ich habe
immer Witze darüber gemacht dass er
aufsprang und Anzing Zettel an die Tafel
zu machen und zu fragen wie ist das und
wir meinten na ja nicht so richtig gut
dann hängt er etwas anderes hin aber
irgendwann sprang er auf und nahm die
Simpsons und stellte sie am
Donnerstagabend gegen die Cosby Show er
wollte diese winzige kleine Sendung mit
der wir gerade erst angefangen hatten
gegen die Nummer eins im Fernsehen
antreten lassen und zuerst dachten wir
ehrlich gesagt alle er sei verrückt wir
sagten das können wir nicht machen wir
werden vernichtet und er sagte immer
wieder vertraut mir das wird
funktionieren das Ding war zu 100%
rupertsidee während Mörder ins
amerikanische Fernsehen expandierte er
löste er in London eine Revolte der
mächtigen britischen
pressegewerkschaften aus
das sollte die Hauptstadt der Zeitungen
sein und all die Arbeit ist durch die
Aktivitäten der Londoner Gewerkschaften
verloren gegangen um die
Zeitungsproduktion zu automatisieren
verlegte murdoxy von der Fleet Street in
einen Werk im Londoner Hafenviertel
wapping
das neue effiziente Werk brauchte
weniger Arbeitskräfte über 5000 weniger
Mörder plante sie alle zur entlassen
als ehemalige Generalsekretärin der
britischen druckergewerkschaft zorget
verhandelte Baroness
um Arbeitsplätze zu retten hey taken er
war verständlicherweise der Meinung dass
er nicht mit den alten Arbeitspraktiken
aus der Fleet Street in ein neues Werk
umzieht dass diese alten nicht brauchte
was er wollte das war ein extrem
radikales Abkommen im Unternehmen aber
das wird er nicht bekommen wir waren
immer noch bereit zu verhandeln und er
hörte zu und sagte am Ende die Musik hat
sich geändert aber der Tanz bleibt
derselbe music heißt changed
was Brender Dean nicht wusste war dass
Mörder bereits seine geheime Abmachung
mit der elektrikergewerkschaft getroffen
hatte um schnell mit einer
probedruckauflage voranzukommen und
deine Kurs Worms als wir wussten dass
sie einen Probelauf durchführten sagte
ich als Generalsekretärin zum ersten Mal
zu unseren Leuten Start auf streikt
heute
live
[Musik]
madok bekam Unterstützung von einer
alten Freundin Margaret Thatcher die das
Management den Gewerkschaften vorzog er
hatte sie unterstützt als sie als
Premierministerin kandidierte und das
zahlte sich aus Regierung
Ellis Gesetze und in dem internationalen
Nachrichten Streit dem walping-streit
ihr bekannt wurde wurde die sogenannte
feindliche Gesetzgebung zu einem
Schlüsselfaktor dafür dass Rupert
Murdock bekam was er wollte
tausende kamen um die Proteste zu
unterstützen aber die Demonstrationen
nahmen eine gewalttätige Wendung
wurde die Festung genannt weil sie
wirklich eine war es gab
Sicherheitsvorkehrungen es wurde eine
Murdock Miliz ausgerufen er wurde
dämonisiert
es gab ziemlich schreckliche Sachen dort
ich habe gesehen wie einige meiner
Mitglieder von der Polizei verprügelt
wurden es wurde Gewalt angewendet kein
Zweifel wir versuchten das zu
kontrollieren aber manchmal konnten
mit Hilfe von Thatcher zerschlug murdok
die Gewerkschaften und sein Werk in
wopping war bald auf dem Vormarsch er
ging ein großes Wagnis ein und es hat
lange gedauert bis er es geschafft hat
es war extrem zerstörerisch für das
Unternehmen sein aber er hat am Ende
bekommen was er wollte he walls wer war
der Boogieman einige der den Arbeitern
den Rücken brach
es war ein bahnbrechender Moment nicht
nur in der Geschichte der Arbeiterschaft
sondern in der Geschichte der Moderne
selbst
er sagte dass es nicht vernünftig das
ist nicht logisch der Fortschritt dass
wir die Regeln ändern
und murdox Einkaufstour ging weiter
1988 kaufte er für 3 Milliarden Dollar
das Edinburgh Magazin Imperium mehr
gesehen Empire zudem auch seventeen the
racing Form und TV Guide gehört zu
murdox schockierender Preis war der
höchste der je für ein Verlagshaus
gezahlt wurde doch dann wurde er durch
Vorschriften gestoppt
der Besitz einer Zeitung und eines
Fernsehsenders in einem einzigen Markt
waren untersagt maddock war gezwungen
seine Geliebte New York Post zu
verkaufen
Jahre später konnte er sie für 25
Millionen Dollar zurückkaufen nachdem er
eine Sondergenehmigung erhalten hatte
er hat die Post am Leben erhalten weil
er sie am Leben erhalten wollte niemand
sonst in der News Corporation wollte das
außer Rupert und die Leute die bei der
Post arbeiteten es macht den
wirtschaftlich
morddock wortwörtlich nach dem Himmel
zunächst ist großes Wagnis war das
Satellitenfernsehen David Hill damals
Spitzenmanager bei twenty first Century
Fox
Sky Fernsehen zu starten gegen eine
hochfinanzierte etablierte Plattform
namens British satellite broadcasting
einem der größten Player aller Zeiten
das trieb das Unternehmen fast in den
Bankrott
das läutete die Explosion des Fernsehens
in ganz Europa und dem Rest der Welt ein
1990 fusionierte Sky mit British
satellite broadcasting zu besgy
murdok behielt 39% des Unternehmens und
mit ihr Rendite seiner Investition ging
bergab
blutete aus und murdok hatte sich durch
seine kauforgien bei den Gläubigern
gefährlich verschuldet glücklicherweise
beschlossen 145 Banken ihm mehr Zeit zu
geben eine Bank in Pittsburgh weigerte
sich jedoch und drohte einen Kredit von
10 Millionen Dollar einzufordern
der packt den er mit den Banken
geschlossen hatte bestand darin dass
wenn eine Bank den Kredit einforderte
alle anderen Kredite auch fällig wurden
mit einem verzweifelten Anruf um fünf
vor zwölf bei der Bank in Pittsburgh
rettete murdok sein Unternehmen vor dem
Zusammenbruch
das war diese unglaubliche Leistung mit
der es geschafft hat das Unternehmen zu
retten er musste Teile davon verkaufen
die Magazine er musste sich zu besseren
Geschäftspraktiken verpflichten die
Banken sagten ihm er müsse sich benehmen
er musste fast 8 Milliarden Dollar
Schulden umstrukturieren das war eine
Nahtoderfahrung für sein Unternehmen und
für Mördern
vorher musste immer alles ganz schnell
gehen und jetzt war er viel
strukturierter
noch 1993 war er zurück am Pokertisch er
gab eine Milliarde Dollar für den
chinesischen Fernsehsender Star TV aus
ein amerikanischer medienanalyst und
Verleger
Rupert murder kam nach China durch Star
das Satellitenfernsehen dass er in
Hongkong aufbaute
dadurch hatte er in den frühen 90ern
breiten Zugang zu einem Medienmarkt der
dem Rest der westlichen Sender im Grunde
verschlossen war
am 1 September 93 verspielte er diesen
Zugang murdok hielt eine Rede in London
die die chinesische Regierung entzündete
als erstes eine Technologie die
Fortschritte in der
telekommunikationstechnologie haben sich
als eindeutige Bedrohung für totalitäre
Regimes erwiesen überall der Chinesen
schlugen zurück indem sie den privaten
Besitz von Satellitenschüsseln verboten
und damit auch murdox Zugang zu
Millionen Haushalten Star TV war unter
Beschuss
murder musste die chinesische Regierung
besänftigen nahm die ungeliebte BBC vom
Sender und vernichtete ein China
kritisches Buch des Ex Gouverneurs von
Hongkong
die chinesische Führung war besänftigt
und murdok fuhr fort chinesische Beamte
zu umwerben um die Präsenz von News Korb
in China
auszuweitensina ist die neue Welt das
ist die Zukunft und er hat das früher
erkannt als die meisten anderen aber
fast nichts funktioniert in China sein
Konkurrent war die chinesische Regierung
mit der chinesischen Regierung kann er
nicht konkurriert
ist kein großer Sportfan doch im
Dezember 93 nahm er eine amerikanische
Obsession ins Visier
Football und er traf mit einem
atemberaubenden Angebot von über
anderthalb Milliarden Dollar schnappte
er sich die Rechte an den National fo
fossilen von cbns dann the wild
einer ich glaube nicht dass wir jemals
einen Deal gemacht haben bei dem wir am
nächsten Morgen nicht mit
Gewissensbissen aufgewacht sind aber das
ist eigentlich gut denn es spornt dich
an noch härter zu arbeiten
für die NFL hätte das ein großer FuPa
sein können
die Football-Liga war sehr mutig denn
Fox hatte nichts keine Sportabteilung
John Maddens Witz war wir sollten froh
sein ich habe Fox Sport gesehen wir sind
Fox Sport Singular sie sind ein riesiges
Risiko eingegangen was würden Sie tun
wenn Sie es vermasseln wenn unsere Show
vor dem Spiel ein Scherbenhaufen gewesen
wäre wenn das Set auseinandergefallen
wäre und dann wenn die Übertragung
beginnt wir die Touchdowns verpassen oh
wir haben es nicht drauf die Ansager
liegen falsch
[Musik]
und was wäre wenn er nicht alle
Amerikaner erreichen würde die Football
Leben murdok zuckte nicht mit der Wimper
er investierte weitere 500 Millionen
Dollar in New World communications
aus dem versierten Investoren
wechselte daraufhin mit 12 seiner
wichtigsten Fernsehsender zu Fox
es war die größte senderumstellung in
der Geschichte des US-Fernsehens und ein
Glücksfall für die lokalen Sender die
NFL auf FOX trinkt jährlich über 900
Millionen Dollar ein und hat bis zu 20
Millionen Zuschauer die Woche
Mörder war auf dem aufsteigenden Ast
wollte aber zu seinen Wurzeln
zurückkehren er fand sich in der
Fernsehbranche wieder die er gar nicht
mag ich glaube er hat nie eine volle
Stunde Fernsehen zur Hauptsendezeit
geguckt aber er mag das
Nachrichtengeschäft Mitte der 90er Jahre
wollte murdok den einzigen 24-stündigen
Nachrichtensender CNN kaufen
aber dessen Turner verachtete murdox
Politik und seine Ansprüche und das
beruhte auf Gegenseitigkeit
Körner verkaufte CNN schließlich
widerwillig aber nicht an Mörder
1996 ging der Sender im Rahmen einer 7,5
Milliarden Dollar Fusion mit Turner
Broadcasting an Time Warner
murd musste sich etwas anderes einfallen
lassen er ließ sich nicht beirren und
gründete seinen eigenen Sender um sich
mit CNN zu messen
etablierte sich schnell als Bühne für
konservative Ansichten
ein Teil des Geschäftsplans ist man
sollte nicht mit CNN konkurrieren Orient
sollte sich um das unterversorgte
Publikum bemühen und man sollte das so
machen dass es billiger ist als Reporter
in die ganze Welt zu schicken also
hatten wir nur Kommentatoren und das
funktionierte und zwar unglaublich gut
einen ex-berater konservativer Politiker
und republikanischer Präsidenten von
Richard Nixon bis George Bush Rupert ist
von Natur aus konservativ vielleicht
nicht so konservativ wie Roger ales aber
ihm gefiel die Tatsache dass Roger einen
Plan für Fox News hatte Fox hatte zu
Beginn viel Geld verloren Rupert musste
sogar Kabelanbieter bezahlen damit sie
es übernehmen es war lebendig kontrovers
und machte die Liberalen Wahnsinn
Amerikaner und auch die ausländischen
Verbündeten die aktiv gegen unser
Militär Arbeiten sobald der Krieg
begonnen hat betrachte ich als
Staatsfeinde
mit dem Slogan fair und ausgewogen
besteht der ehemalige Präsident und CEO
von News Kork Peter Turner darauf das
Fox News seinen Unterschied zwischen
Nachrichten und talkschossen es gibt
Nachrichten bei Fox News die tatsächlich
sehr neutral und moderat und fair
präsentiert werden und dann gibt es Talk
und meinungs-shows von denen niemand
behauptet dass Sie Nachrichten oder
sachlich sind
oder Sean sind eindeutig Leute auf der
rechten Seite des Spektrums sie wurden
aber auch immer als solche präsentiert
überholte CNN und wurde zum
profitabelsten kabel-nachrichtensender
in den USA
doch in murdox Privatleben braute sich
etwas zusammen
1999 ließ er sich nach 32 Jahren von
seiner Frau Anna scheiden mit einer der
größten Abfindungen der Geschichte und
der 68-Jährige murdok heiratete direkt
die 30-Jährige Wendy dann eine
Absolventin der Yale School of
Management und ehemalige Vizepräsidentin
von Star TV murdox persönliches Leben
schien wieder in Ordnung zu sein weniger
als ein Jahr später wurde bei ihm
Prostatakrebs diagnostiziert
aber er hielt euch unsere bekam ein Kind
und dann noch ein weiteres
mit 70 Jahren bekam er seine Tochter
Grace und mit 72 seine Tochter Chloe
2003 im Alter von 72 Jahren zielte
murdok auf eine weitere fernsehtrophäe
direkt TV
er wollte schon seit einem Jahrzehnt ein
satellitengeschäft in den USA er
verhandelte fast zwei Jahre lang mit den
Vorstand von General Motors
an der gewann direct TV
sein 6,6 Milliarden dollar-angebot
sicherte ihm einen Anteil von 34%. aber
eine bizarre Kette von Ereignissen zwang
ihn nur ein Jahr später dazu ihn wieder
aufzugeben während er 2004 die
Wiederwahl von George Bush feierte über
sah Murdock dass ein riesiges
Aktienpaket seines Unternehmens News
Korb in Australien auf den Markt kam
der us-medien-mogul John Malone
schnappte sie sich als sie in den
amerikanischen Markt übertragen wurden
Rupert wachte eines Morgens auf und
sagte heiliger Bimbam dieser Typ besitzt
16 Prozent meines Unternehmens er weiß
ja dass John Malone ein cleverer
Geschäftsmann ist melones Anteil an News
Korb war nun der zweitgrößte nach murdox
um diesen Anteil an seinem Unternehmen
zurückzubekommen
erheblichem Wert abgeben um John Malone
loszuwerden musste er diesen Anteil
schließlich gegen direkt TV eintauschen
ich glaube er wollte vielleicht an
directv festhalten das war inzwischen
ein wirklich starker Programmanbieter
und Rupert hatte keine nationalen
Vertrieb das hätte ihm wahrscheinlich
gefallen
nachdem er seine Aktien zurückgewonnen
hatte kaufte Murdock 2005 die
Internetplattform MySpace
er zahlte einen hohen Preis um einen
Konkurrenten auszustechen
diesmal Sammler Redstone von beyer.com
ist eine komische vielleicht aus seiner
Sicht eine tragisch komische
schmeißbase das war wissen sie er kaufte
nicht ich glaube etwas mehr als 500
Millionen Dollar es gab einen Zeitpunkt
da wurde sogar auf 25 Milliarden
geschätzt und jetzt war es Schrott
der Versuch galt als Desaster
MySpace wurde von Facebook in den
Schatten gestellt also kehrte murdok auf
bekannteste ran zurück und richtete
seinen Blick auf eine der angesehensten
Zeitungen der Welt
Sarah Alison ist Autorin von war at the
Wall Street Journal und war früher
Reporterin bei der Zeitung als ich mit
Leuten über Mörder und seine Vorliebe
für das Wall Street Journal sprach
sagten sogar seine Kinder sie könnten
sich an keine Zeit erinnern in der er
nicht über die Zeitung gesprochen hätte
das Wall Street Journal und die
Muttergesellschaft Dow Jones waren im
Besitz der Minecrafts einer prominenten
Bostoner Familie die sich eher wenig
Beteiligten
hat schon drei mal versucht das Wall
Street Journal zu kaufen
ihn einfach abgewiesen auf eine
unglaublich hochmütige snobistische Art
snow beschway
zum ersten Mal von dem Zerwürfnis in der
bangkok-familie erfuhr der die Zeitung
seit über 100 Jahren gehörte setzte er
schon die Krallen
madok nutzte den Moment und machte ein
Angebot die Aktie wurde für 36 Dollar
gehandelt
ist ehemaliger Vizepräsident und
Direktor von Dow Jones
ich erinnere mich genau ich war
geschockt enttäuscht darüber dass mein
Journalismus mit dem Unternehmen enden
würde für das sich hart gearbeitet hatte
um gute Ausgaben für das Wallstreet
Journal zu machen und dass sie von einem
Mann übernommen wird den ich nicht
wirklich bewunderte
das schwindelerregende Angebot spaltete
die bencraft-familie noch mehr
da waren jetzt Kinder die drohten ihre
Eltern zu verklagen wenn sie an murder
verkaufen ich dachte es würde dem
Ansehen des Wall Street Journal schaden
wenn er die journalistischen Prinzipien
anwendet die er ja fast sein ganzes
Leben lang verfolgt hat nämlich seine
Feinde anzugreifen seine Ende zu
unterstützen und Politiker zu
unterstützen die ihm zu Vorteilen
verhelfen könnten
murdok versprach die Qualität der
Zeitung zu erhalten und die Mitarbeiter
zu übernehmen
unabhängig bleiben ich sag nichts mehr
ich habe gesehen dass er den Eigentümern
immer mehr Versprechen gemacht und sie
dann gebrochen hat er versprache würde
die Standards der times of London
beibehalten und an dem Redakteur Harry
Evans festhalten und innerhalb eines
Jahres hat er Evans gefeuert
doch kein Angebot war so attraktiv wie
murder 6 Milliarden Dollar
also gaben die Minecrafts nach am 1
August 2007 schloss Dow Jones eine
Vereinbarung mit newscore
ging an murder
ich habe so eine Aufregung mitbekommen
lasse das chiano gekauft hat dieses
enorme Gefühl der Befriedigung und er
dachte über sein Leben nach auf er wird
wirklich Zeit mit diesem Journal
verbringen
nicht jeder war so begeistert davon
wir sind heute hier um allen zu sagen
dass Sie wissen sollten dass Rupert
Mörder das Wall Street Journal gekauft
hat wenig überraschend brach murdok bald
seine Versprechen und holte seine
eigenen Leute rein hallo es gelang ihm
sozusagen durch die Hintertür die Kultur
mit einem Schlag kaputt zu machen und
das Ego der Leute die beim Wallstreet
Journal arbeiteten anzukratzen
doch murdok überraschte viele seiner
Kritiker das Wall Street Journal
überholte die USA Today und wurde zu
Nummer eins der Tageszeitungen in
Amerika
der Löwe im Winter wurde 2011 80 Jahre
alt nach 60 Jahren an der Spitze eines
Medien Imperiums stellte sich die Frage
wer ihm nachfolgen würde ich glaube er
freut sich auf den Tag an dem seine drei
Kinder die sich für das Unternehmen
interessieren gemeinsam für ihn arbeiten
er freut sich auf den Tag an dem es
Rupert mal 4 gibt madok kaufte die
Fernsehproduktionsfirma Schein seiner
Tochter Elizabeth für fast 700 Millionen
Dollar
Lächeln kehrte nach einer erfolglosen
Karriere bei News Korb nach Australien
zurück um den Sender Network Ten zu
leiten der jüngste Sohn James wurde
stellvertretende Geschäftsführer bei
News Korb in New York wir sind sehr
wettbewerbsorientiert und zwar in dem
Maß dass wir dort wo wir Marktanteile
gewinnen müssen diese auch erobern
werden dieser wettbewerbsgeist sickerte
in die Unternehmenskultur ein mit
verheerenden Folgen
Medien enthüllten dass die
Boulevardzeitung News of the World die
Sprachnachrichten eines jungen
Mordopfers und ihrer Familie abhörte
und die Polizei für Informationen
bezahlt
wurde das als ein weiterer kleiner
schmutziger Skandal einiger Journalisten
angesehen die mit private Detektiven zu
weit gegangen waren aber was wir für
einen relativ begrenzten Skandal hielten
entpuppte sich als ein allgegenwärtiger
systematischer Missbrauch
journalistischer macht
auch die Handys von Prominenten und
Politikern wurden gehackt
stellte sich heraus dass dieses Telefon
hacking weit verbreitet war das ist
praktisch mit jedem gemacht wurde der
die Möglichkeit Boot Nachrichten oder
Klatsch zu liefern
um den Skandal einzudämmen wurde die 168
Jahre alte News of the World im Juli
2011 geschlossen
murdog entschuldigte sich vor einem
britischen Parlamentsausschuss ich
möchte nur eins sagen dies ist der
demütigste Tag meines Lebens seine
Mitarbeiter hätten ihnen über das
hacking in die Irre geführt
Leute denen nicht vertraut habe ich sage
nicht wer und ich weiß nicht wie oft sie
mich im Stich gelassen haben aber sie
haben sich schändlich Verhalten und das
Unternehmen und mich verraten
mitten in der Anhörung versuchte ein
Demonstrant murdok mit einer Torte
anzugreifen seine Frau Wendy beschützte
ihn
der Skandal war schädlich und
kostspielig
James der Erbe trat als Vorsitzender von
be skyby zurück und News Korb zahlte
über 380 Millionen Dollar an
Rechtskosten und vergleichszahlungen
zwei Jahren nach dem Wendy murdok ihren
Mann verteidigt hatte reichte Rupert
murdok die Scheidung ein
er rief Fox Sports Network ins Leben um
mit ESPN zu konkurrieren und um die
Aktionäre zu besänftigen spaltete murdok
im Juni 2013 seinen sechs Jahrzehnte
altes Verlagsgeschäft vom Rest des
Medienimperiums
das neue Unternehmen nimmt heute
offiziell den Handel auf es ist bereits
der größte Zeitungsverlag der
Vereinigten Staaten mit einem Marktwert
von 8,8 Milliarden Dollar
Murdock hat ein riesiges und
vielfältiges Imperium aufgebaut eine
konkurrenzlose und unaufhaltsame
Zentrale der macht dies ist ein Mann der
sowohl in wirtschaftlicher als auch in
politischer und kultureller Hinsicht
außerordentlich mächtig ist
[Musik]
Charakteristische an ihm was ihn zu
einem pressebaron macht ist dieses
ständige Streben nach mehr und mehr
Macht fest und das ist es auch woran wir
uns erinnern werden
[Musik]